bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna 360
voici lé titre à gérard larcher au
secours de la démocratie représentative
un bien précieux selon le président du
sénat devant la presse parlementaire il
a rappelé l'utilité du bicamérisme après
la lettre d' emmanuel macron qui appelle
les français à s'interroger sur le rôle
du sénat
vous l'entendrez dans un instant
emmanuel macron s'est dit ouvert sur les
80 km heure le chef de l'état est prêt à
des aménagements depuis un an le sénat
milite pour une ouverture de
concertation au sein des départements
afin d' attaque d'adapter cette nouvelle
limitation de vitesse reportages et
débats dans cette édition première
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement de l'année 2019 au sénat
parmi les thèmes cet après midi le grand
débat national
une séance à suivre en direct et en
exclusivité sur notre antenne et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez d'ailleurs
réagir sur twitter avec le hashtag sénat
360 pour accompagner à cet après midi
alexandre poussard dans l'hémicycle est
en train lui pour l'érection des
sénateurs et des ministres à l'actualité
le multiplex parlementaire s'est tout de
suite
et on prend tout de suite est la
direction de l'hémicycle mon attend
alexandre poussard bonjour alexandre
quel est l'ordre du jour de cette
première séance de l'année et bien
définies y aura beaucoup de questions
sur ce grand débat national qui a été
officiellement lancée cette semaine et
ce qui préoccupe les sénateurs c'est la
réforme des institutions puisque vous
l'avez dit emmanuel macron dans sa
lettre aux français a mis en question le
rôle du sénat et gérard larcher
ce matin dans sa conférence de presse a
défendu l'importance du sénat du
bicamérisme pour l'équilibré des
institutions de la vème république et il
a même rendu public un son entretien
avec emmanuel macron à l'elysée il a
affirmé qu emmanuel macron ne souhaitait
pas fusionner le sénat et le conseil
économique social et environnemental
et puis dans cette quête dans cette
séance de questions il y aura des
questions sur le mouvement des gilet
jaune
plus généralement et notamment sur la
liberté de la presse car il ya eu de
nombreuses agressions de journalistes
dans ses week-ends de manifestations d
gilet jaune
et puis les sénateurs interrogeront le
gouvernement sur les conséquences de ce
mouvement sur les petits commerces car
beaucoup de petits commerçants de petits
patrons doit doivent mettre la clé sous
la porte en à cause de déblocage et des
violences lors de ces manifestations
et puis enfin il y aura une question sur
la hausse des tarifs des autoroutes un
prêt de 2 % dès le 1er février une
hausse décidée par les sociétés
d'autoroutes en plein mouvement des
gilet jaune
merci à vous alexandre on vous
retrouvera dans un instant je vous
disais en titre gérard larcher n'a pas
du tout apprécié la lettre adressée en
français par emmanuel macron au delà du
fond c'est la forme que le président du
sénat a critiqué il expliqué devant la
presse parlementaire ce matin à
l'occasion de ses voeux écouter vrai
vous préciser que le président de la
république ne m'avait même pas prévenu
de sa lettre ni même que le parlement
allait être questionné alors qu'il avait
su envoyer un message
le 22 décembre pour remercier le sénat
sans la manière dont il s'était comporté
au moment de
du complément vous savez du texte qui
portait complément du projet de loi de
finances je lui ai dit que je pensais
que nous avions des relations loyal
sincère et sk l'avenir nos relations
devraient se limiter à ce qui est prévu
strictement dans la constitution et que
donc j'ai perçu cela il m'a assuré
et je suis pas naïf mais je suis
quelqu'un qui fait confiance il m'a
assuré qu'il n'en était rien donc j'en
donne acte et je lui ai dit que je dirai
publiquement la démocratie
représentative
c'est un bien extrêmement précieux et on
peut pas le livre est uniquement d'aller
dire à l'encan d'un rétablissement
politique transitoire
donc bien sûr que la démocratie
représentative aussi s'interroger mais
sur qui s'appuyer le président de la
république
aujourd'hui si ce n'est sur les premiers
représentants de la démocratie
représentative que sont les conseillers
municipaux les bear la démocratie
représentative
elle va du conseil municipal au
président de la république et donc sur
ce sujet je crois que nous devons être
attentifs mais c'est aussi sa
responsabilité
c'est lui le gardien de la constitution
séduit gardien des principes laïques
démocratique social et décentralisé
voilà le président du sénat qui n'avait
pas apprécié et bien questionnement sur
le rôle du sénat on va retrouver à
présent temps de traduire salle des
conférences bonjour au tam vous allez à
interroger sénateurs et ministres à la
fois sur ce grand débat national dont le
coup d'envoi était donné cette semaine
par emmanuel macron mais aussi sur ces
questions de révision constitutionnelle
et de rôle est d'importance du
bicamérisme et oui bien sûr nous
reviendrons sur cette conférence de
presse de gérard larcher sur on l'a
entendu sa défense du bicamérisme face
aux questions posées sur le sénat par la
lettre aux français emmanuel macron on
l'a entendu à l'instant gérard larcher
s'est montré agacé presque déçu par
l'attitude de l'exécutif
on parlera aussi de sa volonté de
revenir sur le non cumul des mandats
notez d'ailleurs que le président de la
république n'a pas fermé la porte
notamment pour les très petites communes
je parlerai de cela avec mes invités le
sénateur les républicains françois noël
buffet mais aussi le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat patrick kanner il
sera aussi question avait que du
déroulement des nouvelles auditions de
la commission denquête benalla sont
source de nombreuses révélations
notamment hier on a entendu et bien
qu'il y avait une vingtaine de voyages
effective par l'ex chargé de mission à
l'elysée
et cela bien sûr avant l'audition du
principal intéressé sur ce volet bien
sûr des passeports diplomatiques et puis
sachez qu'après la séance de questions
d'actualité
nous aurons à mon micro la ministre des
affaires européennes nathalie loiseau
cela alors que la perspective du break
si dur du no deal se rapproche chaque
jour
merci à vous attend à présent place aux
débats et aux reportages aujourd'hui et
nous consacrons notre dossier cette
question de la limitation de vitesse à
80 km/heure avant-hier le chef de l'état
s'est dit ouvert à des aménagements sur
cette limitation souvent vécue par de
nombreux départements comme pénalisante
en tous les cas
d'après les travaux du sénat avant d'en
parler avec mes invités je me propose de
voir ce reportage on essonne d'adrien
levené c'était l'un des feuilletons de
l'été est l'une des revendications des
gilets jaunes dans le département de
l'essonne comme sur le reste du
territoire la mise en place des 80 km
heure a provoqué la colère des
automobilistes réaction de dépit d'abord
et puis malheureusement aussi quelques
actes de vandalisme comme nous l'avons
vu partout sur le territoire avec
beaucoup de radars qui ont été dégradés
qui sont aujourd'hui inutilisables
la moitié des radars du département ont
été dégradées depuis juillet dernier
dans l'essonne 85% des routes concernées
sont passés aux 80 km heure une mesure
néanmoins efficace en terme de sécurité
routière selon le gouvernement en
attendant les chiffres officiels la
ministre jacqueline gourault se félicite
déjà des premiers résultats et résultat
de la mise en place du 80 km/heure ont
porté leurs fruits
sinon je ne peux pas préciser parce que
les chiffres ne sont pas encore sorti
officiellement que l'ordre
mais vous verrez le gouvernement a prévu
que la mesure permettrait de sauver
entre 300 et 400 vies par an un chiffre
contesté par certaines associations
d'automobilistes
nous pouvons espérer une petite baisse
du nombre de tués sur les routes mais
bien inférieur à ce qui a justifié la
mesure
malheureusement bien inférieur la
question des 80 km arrête un thème du
grand débat national
emmanuel macron a même encourager les
maires à lui faire des propositions pour
adapter le dispositif car tous les
acteurs regrette la mise en place
précipitée de la mesure sans
consultation des élus locaux
c'est sans doute efficace peut-être
efficace mais sans doute très maladroite
dans sa mise en place
c'était encore une fois une espèce de
décisions verticale si ça revient dans
le débat public ça prouve bien que la
décision horizontale la réflexion
horizontal était peut-être intéressante
depuis le début le sénat juge trop
vertical la mise en place des 80
kilomètres heure la semaine prochaine
une proposition de loi pour aménager les
retraits de points du permis de conduire
à cause d'un excès de vitesse sera
discuté dans l'hémicycle une proposition
rejetée par la commission des lois avait
invité sur ce plateau
c'est la très centriste de l'ain vous
êtes à l'origine de cette ppl on va en
parler dans un instant jacques ier loin
de la vo sur ce plateau bonjour vous
êtes délégué général de l'association de
prévention routière bienvenue à vous et
puis deux sénateurs c'est vrai que
perrin bonjour sénateurs
les républicains du territoire de
belfort et jean luc fichet bonjour
sénateur socialiste du finistère frères
question pour vous en avez péché parce
que j'ai fait partie de ce groupe de
travail ici au sénat sur cette réflexion
sur le 80 km heure vous êtes satisfait
par les déclarations des manuels macron
c'était mardi devant les maires
l'air bah écoutez je suis en tous les
cas attentif à ce qu'il a dit parce que
somme toute il ne fait que reprendre ce
que nous avions proposé dans notre
rapport que j'avais écrit avec madame
julien et monsieur raison ou en invitait
tout simplement le premier ministre à
surseoir de six mois pour essayer de
travailler avec les collectivités
locales et essayer de faire en sorte que
cette nouvelle disposition des 80 km
heure soit acceptable par un maximum de
population c'est que l'on sait très bien
qu'une mesure comme celle là ne peut
véritablement fonctionner que si il ya
une adhésion de la population et si les
comportements effectivement s'adapte
progressivement cette nouvelle
disposition ce que semble dire le
présent vaqueront c'est que chance à
abolir cette disposition il invite
maintenant à travailler que les
collectivités pour voir comment on peut
l'adapter au mieux avec les territoires
et avec les départements en prenant en
compte les particularités de chaque
département donc bien évidemment que
nous accueillons cette proposition avec
satisfaction
pourtant ça a été rappelé dans son
reportage ça pourrait sauver 300 à 400
vies par an chacune gros l'heureux
disait eh bien ça a porté ses fruits
cette mesure quelqu'un dit dans le
reportage tout à l'heure ça avait été
fait par verticalité on nous a souvent
stigmatisé sur cette question et je
crois qu'ici personne sur ce plateau et
personne au sénat et je pense que dans
l'immense majorité des français n'est
contre la sécurité routière bien
évidemment on a tous pour objectif que
de faire diminuer le nombre de morts sur
la route c'est bien logique mais cette
mesure est arrivé de manière verticale
gel disait très dogmatique et surtout on
a voulu nous culpabiliser en disant vous
êtes contre les 81 kg 30 donc c'est
parce que en gros vous n'êtes pas pour
la sécurité au terme ce qui est
complètement faux
ce qu'on regarde nous ce qu'on constate
c'est que sur nos territoires parce que
nous sommes des élus ruraux locaux et on
sait comment ça fonctionne on a on prend
nos deux voitures tous les jours on voit
bien comme tous les autres l'ensemble
des automobilistes que cette mesure ne
ne fonctionne pas et aujourd'hui je
crois que là la décision du président de
la république 2
mettre un peu d'eau dans son vin et de
se rendre compte qu'il existe des corps
intermédiaires dont on parle tant ces
derniers jours qu'ils sont là pour aussi
peut-être faire remonter un certain
nombre d'informations et bien ces élus
et toutes ces personnes qui a modelé se
sont exprimés sur cette question avec
quelque peu raison et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le fait de vouloir enfin
réfléchir à redonner au département la
possibilité de mettre en oeuvre une
politique de limitation de la vitesse
qui soit une politique qui soit
territorialisée et donc pragmatique et
bien c'est une excellente chose est ce
que c'est ce que nous proposons ici
depuis un an et demi et c'est ce que
j'espère nous arriverons à mettre en
oeuvre parce que regarder moi j'ai été
maire et nous sommes un certain nombre à
avoir été maire très longtemps dans nos
communes on nous laissait la
responsabilité de mettre en place des
zones vannes des zones 30 des zones 40
ou 50 et je pense que ça fonctionne très
bien on est responsable de ces choses là
je pense que le département peut le
faire et on a la chance dans ce pays
aussi d'avoir une association
extrêmement bien implanté que la
prévention routière avec laquelle d'une
l'ensemble des élus travaillent de
manière très efficace qui est là aussi
peut être en capacité de fournir des
informations des conseils et je pense
que tous ensemble si le dialogue se met
enfin en place parce que c'est un sujet
important le dialogue dans ce pays
depuis un certain temps nous a beaucoup
oublié si le dialogue se met enfin en
place on va pouvoir trouver des
solutions qui soient des solutions qui
permettent de qui convienne à tout le
monde y ait des endroits on peut rouler
à 70 et on a d'autres on peut pas rouler
l'adhésion de la population à cette
mesure a été à l'abaissement de la
limitation à 80 km h alors en ce qui
concerne notre association vous savez
qu'on participe aux travaux du cnsr du
conseil national à la sécurité routière
et cette mesure elle était dans les
tiroirs ou dans les cartons je ne sais
pas où elle était mais enfin elle était
là depuis très longtemps parce que les
experts en sécurité routière savent très
bien par leurs travaux que le paramètre
de la vitesse et ça c'est vraiment
mathématiques c'est un paramètre si on
déplace le curseur vers moins de vitesse
et bien on réduit de toute façon
l'accidentalité globalement donc le
nombre de morts est réduit le nombre de
blessés graves est également réduit donc
notre association en conscience elle a
soutenu cette mesure après
nous on est pas on n'est pas aux
affaires c'est pas nous qui décidons les
choses ce qu'on peut faire et je vous
remercie de l'avoir signalé c'est
effectivement accompagné sur la
pédagogie autour de cette mesure vous
savez que notre association attaquer les
propos d' emmanuel macron qui ouvre la
porte visiblement à des aménagements
alors vous savez que l'être humain a une
faculté c'est toujours n'entendre que ce
qu'ils avaient envie d'entendre et
d'interpréter en fonction de ses propres
intérêts moi ce que j'ai entendu c'est
il faut ensemble qu'on trouve une
manière plus intelligente de la mettre
en oeuvre quand il parlait de cette
mesure
et là moi je ne peux être que d'accord
et je veux dire effectivement dans la
manière de mettre en oeuvre cette mesure
sans bien sûr renoncer car il ne faut
pas renoncer
et bien c'est tout ce qui est tout ce
qui tourne autour de la prévention de la
pédagogie de l'information et là les
collectivités locales les mairies et les
élus locaux sont vraiment importants
notre association elle a créé un label
qui s'appelle ville prudente et un label
qui est destiné aux communes qui et
agissent en termes de prévention
routière on a récompensé les 134
première commune cette année
eh bien les élus locaux quand on discute
avec eux deux ces mesures-là y comprenne
pourquoi ils comprennent on en avait
parlé ensemble les zones 30 et même un
peu moins besoin qu'on les aide dans la
pédagogie par rapport à céret goy
chavent ayant le rappeler c'est sur
votre proposition de loi qui a été
rejetée en combien je reçois oui on va
en parler alors cette proposition a pour
but de permettre aux automobilistes
qu'ils perdent le premier petit point
qui est bien le premier point de le
récupérer au bout de trois mois au lieu
de six mois pourquoi parce que souvent
c'est la loi des séries
les gens vont perdre un premier petit
point et puis avant six mois ils en
perdent un second et puis et puis après
ils se disent voilà je suis parti pour
deux ans et quelquefois il ya surtout
dans les territoires ruraux et
périurbains un sentiment d'être toujours
les personnes stigmatisées
donc du coup voilà ils payent plusieurs
fois et après il ya comme une forme j'ai
envie de dire de laisser aller parce
qu'ils se disent bah voila je
récupérerai j'ai remis mes points tout
le monde ne peut pas se payer les stages
il faut aussi bien le dire
et cette proposition de loi n'a rien à
voir finalement avec le 80
kilomètres/heure alors bien sûr c'est
dans le titre ça aurait pas parce que
c'est ça c'est ce qui donne l'idée c'est
cette fracture entre les territoires qui
m'a motivé à lancer cette proposition de
loi c'est à dire qu'il faut que les gens
que ce soit en ville ou à la campagne
puisse continuer à rouler avec tous
leurs points et un permis de conduire et
donc des assurances voilà donc et c'est
dommage que en cette période où il ya
quand même le mouvement des gilet jaune
avec cette grande ce grand sentiment
d'injustice dans le territoire que le
sénat ne que la commission des lois
n'est pas repris cette proposition
parce que finalement elle n'est pas
opposée du tout à la sécurité et si le
80 km heure permet bien sûr de sauver
des vies il faut bien sûr l'appliquer
mais on peut aussi la tendance à 50
km/heure aussi bien on aura encore
débuté effectivement j'étais rapporté la
commission des lois de de la ppl de même
brèche avant et à cesser cette pollution
doit elle mérite effectivement de
réinterroger de réfléchir sur le permis
à points qui est un outil pédagogique de
d'amélioration de la sécurité routière
dans la discussion qui était proposée
effectivement de réduire de 6 mois 3mois
suspension du point
de façon à ne pas pénaliser les gens là
lecture qu'on a fait nous c'est
qu'effectivement ça détruisait comme
l'aspect pédagogique du permis à points
pas du tout non mais c'est direct qu'on
a fait et puis il faut quand même savoir
une chose c'est que ça autorise tout
d'un coup les comportements excessifs
parce qu' on se dit au bout de trois
mois je récupère mon point c'est pas
très grave
quand il s'agit de passer de 80 90 on
peut dire qu'on n'est pas sûr d ex
extrême ça autorise aussi des chauffeurs
à passer de 110 à 129 km heure et à ne
perdre qu'un point pour trois mois
et là pour le coup c'est tout découvrir
un petit peu les vannes et on pense que
il y a à réfléchir sur cette question là
donc la commission des lois la rejeter
le débat aura lieu quand même dans
l'hémicycle sur cette question moi je je
voudrais revenir plus globalement sur
certains sur cette fameuse mise en
oeuvre des 80 km moi je me suis opposé
dès le départ je me suis opposé parce
que je considérais depuis le début ce
n'était pas une mesure qui était utile
mais surtout parce que est en rapport
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui est que
les gilet jaune etc
je pense qu'on n'est pas dans une crise
sociale on est dans une crise sociétale
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la question
que j'ai dit et je lui en ai de l'île
d'ici sur votre plateau sur bien
d'autres plateaux au moins la question
que je me pose c'est quelle société on
veut construire à l'avenir
est ce que c'est une société française
fait d'interdît où plus personne n'a
rien droit de faire sans avoir
l'autorisation d'en haut et où toute
honte d'en haut sans que personne n'ait
son mot à dire où est ce qu'on veut on
le sait un peu de liberté aux gens je
pense qu'on peut pas non plus en
permanence vouloir tout interdire et la
question des 80 km soit je pense que
c'était la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase et ça a été a sans
doute un des uns des nombreux éléments
déclencheurs mais ça on a été un et
cause concernant l'histoire de delà du
point moi je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être aussi réfléchir ça je lance le
truc mais réfléchir aussi à une
gradation de la peine parce que vous
rouliez à 51 ou à 79 km à vous avez la
même peine est ce que c'est bien la
bonne chose moi j'habite à la frontière
suisse que vous assurer que si vous
roulez à delhi mais il ya différentes
strates commencera de dewitt seuil de
vitesse merci qui font que vous avez des
peines qui sont différentes
je pense qu'il ya peut-être des
réflexions autour de ça et avant est ce
qu'on disait nous c'est avant de
réfléchir aux 80 km/heure peut-être
faudrait-il réfléchir à la conduite sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants conduite soit
l'art de l'alcool il ya beaucoup de
sujets il faut faire de la pédagogie
autres choisir la réponse tombe à
revenir au 4
alors ça c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
sujet si on laisse la liberté ce qui
avait été proposé que chaque que
finalement élu sur le territoire de sa
copine sa commune ou bien au niveau du
conseil départemental voire au niveau de
la région et une autonomie par rapport
au choix des limitations de vitesse en
fait on va dans le sens inverse de ce
que demandent les français nous vous
savez on est implanté dans 96
départements on est comme vous le disiez
on est vraiment très très proche de ce
qui se passe dans les territoires
est ce qu'on nous dit souvent c'est ce
qui est compliqué c'est que sur la route
ça change tout le temps vous l'avez dû
entendre cette phrase là on nous dit ça
change tout le temps de vitesse etc
imaginez un pays dans lequel chaque
chaque collectivité locale puisse
déterminer
choisir les ses propres limitations de
vitesse vous avez raison aujourd'hui
les élus peuvent se croiser en nous
comme une simple espèces ça se passe
mais toujours dans la base c'est très
limité toujours à l'abri fond on ne peut
pas ça mais ça c'est un principe a dit
la nisa trois là mais on ne peut pas
aller si des eaux de surface et de
droits nationaux
donc il est il est bon pour qu'une règle
vous savez mieux que moi dans cette
enceinte et vu votre votre quotidien
qu'une règle il faut qu'elles soient
lisibles et simple pour avoir des
chances d'être appliquées faudra alors
parce que si on l'avait sur l'ex fis on
lui donne aucune chance de réussir en ce
qui concerne le 80 km heure c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est en
matière de sécurité routière et vous le
savez très bien on a eu les mêmes débats
sur le port de la ceinture de sécurité
on a dû tout ce passé notre permis avec
60 kilomètres heure en ville aujourd'hui
on roule à 50 et souvent à 30
beaucoup trop jeune mais qu'est ce qui
se passe sur ces sujets là et que l'on
sait être des sujets irritante parce que
c'est des sujets qui pour les français
sont considérés comme des privations de
liberté et bien sur ces sujets là il
faut absolument accompagné de pédagogie
de manière à ce qu'il soit compris mais
il faut aussi beaucoup trop quand il
faut aussi beaucoup de temps pour que
les français les adoptent c'est donc
laissons à celle ci n'a quand même du
vin dans les sons à celle ci le temps de
faire ses preuves
et quand les français auront vu que
c'est mais cette mesure est bonne
et bien croyez moi ils voudront pas
repartir ça va être compliqué elle a
atteint un tel niveau d'impopularité
cette mesure avec le mouvement du jaune
avant justement moi je pense que le côté
pédagogique de ma proposition de loi il
y est toujours
il faut pas prendre les français pour
plus bêtes qui ne sont ils ont bien
compris que il y avait des périodes
pendant laquelle il faut faire très
attention on peut perdre un deuxième
point ne croyez pas que au lendemain
quand ils ont 12 points d'un seul coup
il se met à ne plus faire attention du
tout enfin je pense que le côté
pédagogique de trois mois au lieu de six
mois il y est toujours
l'amande l'y ai toujours on parle
toujours bien du premier petit point ce
à dire en parle pas des grands
délinquants de la route qui eux sont
toujours pénalisé fortement et c'est
très important
et puis
je reviens sur sept ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes et qui quand même profond
qui ne touche pas que les gens qui
aujourd'hui sont sur les ronds-points et
comme une forte proportion de la
population qui pense que la france est
injuste et je crois que avoir un signal
un peu en leur direction surtout pour
les territoires ruraux et périurbains je
crois que ce serait quand même assez
important et vraiment d'être rapidement
sur ce que disait ma collègue parce que
on le constate comme tout dans nos
territoires les gens qui malheureusement
décède en veillant voiture c'est pas
parce qu'il roulait à 92 km heure et
qu'il il dépassé la limite de deux
kilomètres quand elle est à 90 c'est
parce qu'ils roulent souvent
malheureusement pu constater à 130 140
150 sur des routes qui sont limitées à
90 qui sont dangereux et c'est donc la
direction elle est là celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont pénalisés par la mise
en oeuvre des 80 km heure c'est celles
et ceux qui sont à la limite et qui
respectait la limite là quasiment la
limitation de vitesse qui se retrouvent
aujourd'hui à 9 heures de rouler à 80 il
ya un autre point c'est celui de la
pollution quand même parce que moi j'ai
quoi j'ai fait un constat depuis que la
mise en oeuvre a été fait depuis les 80
kilomètres ont été mis en un mois une
voiture automatique
eh bien ma voiture automatique à 80 km
elle ne tient pas la sixième vitesse
elle mais celui en cinquième mais je
serais curieux de voir quelle est la
consommation accc est la pollution des
tous les véhicules qui roulent à 80 qui
peuvent pas monter il ya deux années
d'expérimentation routière qui
travaillent afin d'y ans quand il va y
avoir des aménagements
il ya peut-être un aspect qu'il faut
prendre en compte aussi sur les 80
km/heure et qui nous a fait réagir c'est
l'éloignement des territoires ruraux et
bien évidemment que ça stand pour nous
un argument important c'est que c'est
vrai que deux ou trois minutes sur un
trajet d'une heure ou six minutes c'est
pas grand chose sauf qu'on voit bien que
nos décideurs économiques
aujourd'hui la minute elle compte et
l'implantation des artisans des
entrepreneurs dans nos territoires
éloignés prend en compte cette distance
et cet éloignement
donc c'est en cela aussi qu'il faut
travailler pour faire en sorte que les
bandes roulantes qui sont aujourd'hui à
80 kilomètres heure mais qui supporte
largement à 90 et ben est plus être
restaurés ou 80 kilomètres heure parce
que en plus est une vitesse optimisée et
mécaniquement en termes de pollution
donc une vitesse acceptable
un labo oui je voulais revenir sur la
question des territoires et cette mesure
elle a souvent été présenté comme étant
contre les territoires ruraux
or il faut avoir quand même en peut-être
quelques chiffres qui sont d'importance
en france on à 54 tués par million
d'habitants au niveau de l'intégralité
du territoire
à paris on est à 16 tués par million
d'habitants dans certains territoires au
peuple français en euros sur lesquels on
a justement ces fameuses routes
départementales bidirectionnelle sans
terre plein central
on monte jusqu'à 100 tués par million
d'habitants et remet donc ça veut dire
que cette mesure
elle n'est pas faite pour les rues pour
les urbains elle n'est pas faite pour
cela elle est faite pour effectivement
dans les territoires faire en sorte que
et vous le savez très bien les gens ils
se tuent par beau temps sur des lignes
droites sur des routes roulante
regardait un peu un reportage ou un
maire montrait une ligne droite à
travers une jolie campagne et en disant
regardez sur cette route là pourquoi
limiter à 80 kilomètres heure alors
qu'elle est si belle et bien c'est
justement là et vous le savez très bien
que les gens se tuent ils se tuent seul
sur des routes droites quand il fait
beau regarder par où l'on regardé les
chiffres de l'accidentel car il sait
aussi qu'on ferme les accidents
intervenus
vous me posez la question à l'instant à
michel que de savoir si la mesure était
morte
je ne sais pas si elle est enterrée ou
pas ce qui est certain c'est quel gâchis
quel gâchis monumental
la commission avait proposé de décaler
de six mois la décision pour qu'on
puisse faire des expérimentations
ça a été refusé en bloc par le premier
ministre la décision était prise on a
appliqué combien a coûté le changement
de l'ensemble des panneaux sur le
territoire national ça c'est une
question on parle de plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros au final qu'est ce
qui s'est passé tous les radars ou en
tout cas
70% des radars sur le territoire
national ont été dégradés et ne sont
plus en état de fonctionner quelle est
la perte de gain et puis surtout quel
est le coût parce que moi j'ai fait un
calcul je crois qu'il ya 2000 les
quelques radars ces 5 sur l'ensemble du
territoire national à 120 milles à 120
me de rôles radars ça fait 1 120
millions d'euros voilà quel gâchis si on
nous avait écoutés on à faire accepter
faire adhérer les français à cette
mesure
oui enfin la pédagogie je pense que les
français ont bien compris et et tous se
sont sensibles au fait qu'ils aient
moins de morts sur les routes
mais on a quand même un souci quand même
de sécurité quand on a derrière soi un
camion qui roule à 80 km/heure compteur
réel et qu'on a une petite voiture et
qu'on est devant avec un conteur un peu
anciens qui affiche 80 mais qui pour
autant enroulé à 75 ou 70 et c'est vrai
que moi je voudrais qu'on mesure
également les accidents qui peut y avoir
ou où les risques qui peut y avoir avec
avec ce point là et puis je reviens sur
la sur le côté pédagogique je crois
qu'il faut faire confiance un peu aux
français alors si on veut plus du tout
de morts sur la route
alors je vais faire un peu de
provocation mais il faut mettre toute la
vitesse à 50 km heure partout une bonne
fois pour toutes
histoire de vraiment parce que mais non
mais voilà même si on veut vraiment
vraiment aller au fond des choses sont
d'accord pour baisser bien sûr la
limitation de vitesse dès lors qu'on va
pas sauver des vies mais alors il faut
aller au bout de la démarche et puis
dire voilà bon bah vous roulez plus à la
campagne va vous organisez des
transports en commun parce qu'il n'y en
a pas que les gens soient obligés à leur
travail dans les deux camps de l'avoir
tué rapidement d'un juste un mot c'est
vrai que quand on voit bien que cette
mesure d'aller parfaitement acceptées
dans la limite des grandes
agglomérations
parce qu'elles sont pas confrontés au
problème d'ailleurs on rencontre de plus
en plus de nos collègues nos amis et à
qui nos même don pas d'action d'hier
il n'a même pas le temps d'y conduire
que chez nous en milieu rural et qui
vont nous expliquer un fonds table de
luxe le curé crcc l'affairé inversion
des guanacos date revenu sur ce plateau
dans le reste de l'actualité au sénat et
je vous le disais
alexandre bénin aurait utilisé vingt
fois c'est passeport depuis elle son
licenciement information révélée hier
par très par patrick strzoda le
directeur de cabinet des manuels macron
n'a été convoquée pas pour la seconde
fois par les sénateurs retour sur ces
missions avec aurélien romanet le
directeur de cabinet des manuels macron
patrick strzoda a fait des révélations
sur l'utilisation des passeports
diplomatiques par alexandre benalla nous
savons aujourd'hui que monsieur benalla
à utiliser presque une vingtaine de fois
ces passeports contre le 1er août 2010 8
et le 31 décembre et la première
utilisation et du 1er août au 7 août
une révélation qui contredit les propos
d'alexandre benalla devant la commission
sénatoriale le 19 septembre il avait
alors assuré avoir laissé les passeports
diplomatiques dans son bureau de
l'elysée patrick strzoda a également
répondu sur les deux passeports de
service révélée par le canard enchaîné
mercredi là encore une révélation
dessine une personnalité peu
scrupuleuses dans l'obtention du second
passeport de service en juin 2018
obtenir ce deuxième passeport messieurs
benalla adressée au ministère de
l'intérieur une note dactylographié a en
tête du chef de cabinet une autre non
signé de façon manuscrite donc
soupçonnant une falsification faite par
monsieur benalla nous avons signalé ce
fait au procureur de la république
un article 40 à quelle date
ce matin patrick strzoda enfin reconnu
devant les sénateurs des
dysfonctionnements et des manque de
réactivité
concernant le téléphone sécurisé dont
alexandre b nana est resté en possession
après son licenciement par l'elysée
confrères serait actuellement en garde à
vue et bien l affaire diplomatique pour
réagir à cette information retourne
salle des conférences attaque vous êtes
avec le sénateur elle est environ le
françois noël buffet les membres de
cette commission d' enquête sénatoriale
sur la ferme et nahla justement oui
effectivement tout d'abord votre
réaction françois noël buffet à cette
information que vient de donner delphine
ça de nos confrères du parisien
alexandre benalla serait donc en garde à
vue
sur la fère un des passeports
diplomatiques oui je ne suis pas surpris
dans la mesure où l'éruption que nous
avons eu hier démontre à l'évidence la
commission d'infractions d'infractions
graves
rédigé un faux en écriture pour obtenir
un passeport quand on avait un passeport
de service le service quand on est dans
son dans sa fonction un certain nombre
de mensonges aussi le fait de ne pas
rendre ces passeports alors que
continuer de voyager 20 voyages entre le
début août et fin décembre
la plainte était déposée par depuis peu
de temps sois pas étonné qu'ils sont en
garde à vue et ça me paraît parfaitement
normal à ce stade
est ce que pour vous et bien alexandre
il ya eu par jour sur la première
audition d'alexandre benalla et faut-il
également que le sénat saisisse la
justice sur ce point je rappelle qu'il
avait été questionné sur les passeports
diplomatiques l'air avait répondu à
l'époque il les avait laissées dans son
bureau
de toute évidence oui et je pense que
les rapporteurs ne diront ce qu'ils
veulent faire
il me paraît parfaitement normal que
nous saisissions une transmission en
tous les cas au procureur de la
république ces éléments là pour qu'il
engage des poursuites nécessaires on ne
peut pas accepter que devant une
commission denquête où l'on prête
serment
on puisse mentir comme cela a été fait
la preuve est apportée
donc il n'y a pas de faiblesse à avoir
sur ce point de vue là on va également
parler français mais le buffet de la
conférence de presse de ce matin de
gérard larcher qui a été longuement
consacrer à sa défense du bicamérisme
comment avez-vous réagi après cette
lettre français adressée par emmanuel
macron en début de semaine où le sénat
est questionné on parle d'une possible
transformation du sénat oui si on est on
est choqué à la manière de faire de
surcroît il n'en avait pas informé le
président du sénat ce qui est d'une
élégance total sur le fond on se rend
bien compte que nous avons besoin d'un
système bicaméral
on ne peut pas supprimer le sénat mais
en france ou ailleurs quand ils existent
c'est un point d'équilibré imaginez
qu'il n'y a pas eu le sénat dans cette
affaire benalla où en serions nous
aujourd'hui nous savons que l'assemblée
nationale et le groupe majoritaire et
muselé dans ses expressions et s'il
n'avait pas le sénat venait pas d'
équilibre la défense des territoires
ce que nous défendons depuis quelques
depuis de nombreuses semaines sur le
budget de la france sur les l'absence
d'économies sur la taxe des produits
pétroliers
nous l'avions dit depuis très longtemps
et plein d'autres sujets si nous n'avons
pas été là et bien il n'y aurait pas eu
de cet équilibre nécessaire au débat
démocratique
voilà entendu l'exécutif n'avait pas
beaucoup écouté d'ailleurs sur ces
sujets mais d y cultive ne nous a pas
écoutés du tout ils commencent à revenir
un peu là dessus mais le système
bicaméral c'est la garantie de la
démocratie en nous sommes dans un pays
démocratique faut-il encore le rappeler
et il y une démocratie représentative
avec des élus qui sont responsables et 7
aux élections que l'on décide de les
garder ou pas les garder que les
français reprennent la parole
donc attention de ne pas pour des
raisons de circonstancielle de ne pas
mettre en péril un système qui en
réalité fonctionne très bien qu'il
évolue qu'il s'adapte il n'y a pas de
doute là dessus on peut débattre de tout
est-ce que l'on peut aussi débattre du
retour sur la réforme sur le non cumul
des mandats on a entendu
gérard larcher qui juge qu'il faut le
faire car il ya de trop nombreuses
années qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
déconnectez laitiers emmanuel macron
n'est pas contre c'est ce qu'il a dit
dans l'eure il ya quelques jours sur les
très petites villes c'est bien dommage
qu'il ne l'ait pas qu'il n'est pas
défavorable avant le président de la
république on se rend bien compte que
cette absence de possibilité de cumuler
un mandat national qui demande à l'autre
constitue une vraie rupture avec le
terrain et cela on le constate mais tous
les jours hennessy la situation
d'aujourd'hui c'est aussi un peu le
résultat de cela regardez les députés de
la république en marche à quel point ils
sont en difficulté voire même absent des
débats
tellement ils sont éloignés du terrain
parce qu'on leur a dit que c'était pas
la peine d'y aller
enfin c'est méconnaître notre système
démocratique la force d'un élu qu'il
siège au plan national c'est d'être
ancré dans son territoire de connaître
les concitoyens de connaître les
problématiques pour apporter les bonnes
solutions
on voit bien que cette absence la cause
de graves problèmes à notre pays
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup françois noël buffet a
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup parlé retour sur cette
conférence de presse de gérard larcher
c'était ce matin devant à la presse
parlementaire avec il n'avait rien dit
depuis la publication de la lettre d'
emmanuel macron où le chef de l'état
interroge les français sur le rôle du
sénat à une possible réforme mais pour
sa conférence de presse de rentrée
gérard larcher a contre attaqué
déplorant d'abord la forme je voudrais
vous préciser que le président de la
république ne m'avait même pas prévenu
de sa lettre ni même que le parlement
allait être questionné les deux hommes
se sont vus lundi en tête à tête et
gérard larcher a été clair sur son refus
de réformer la chambre haute par
référendum
j'ai aussi rappelé au président de la
république l'a dit qu'aucune révision
constitutionnelle ne se fera sans le
strict respect des dispositions prévues
par la loi fondamentale
qu'on se le dise telli sur le grand
débat national gérard larcher salle une
initiative qui fait passer du rond-point
la table ronde sans toutefois cacher ses
réserves
je me suis prononcé pour le grand débat
je suis pas dupe non plus il faut être
prudent faut être vigilant attentif à
toute tentative d'instrumentalisation
il faudra aussi être exigeants sur la
suite que l'exécutif proposera de donner
à cette consultation
enfin le président du sénat a salué un
retour du chef de l'état vers les mers
en rappelant qu'il exhorte depuis des
mois à entendre les territoires et ses
premiers représentants
et comme souvent le président du sénat a
conclu par une main tendue
je crois que la situation nous amène à
la nécessité sur un certain nombre de
sujets de travailler ensemble travailler
ensemble pour écouter et essayer de dire
ensemble bien commun dire le bien commun
ça doit être notre rôle
un franc parler avec des lignes rouges
toujours bien dressé sans fermer la
porte au dialogue
gérard larcher a finalement fait du
gérard larcher rappelant au président de
la république qu'il avait aussi besoin
du sénat pour sortir de cette crise
bonjour bonjour sénateurs à les
indépendants du nord première question
pour vous s'il vient de noël puisque on
a appris ce matin que gérard larcher
avaient finalement découvert que le
président de république dans cette
lettre aux français
eh bien elle les inciter à s'interroger
sur le rôle du sénat vous avez été
froissés par cette injonction du chef de
l'état un petit peu j'ai trouvé que les
termes poser dans le courrier qu'il a
adressé aux français était un petit peu
maladroit dans le sens où ils ciblent
véritablement le sénat comme une
institution sur laquelle se pose des
questions
or à mon avis on est là dans un contexte
où chaque institution doit être mise sur
la table
et puis qu'on puisse discuter librement
de tout cela après attention à ne pas à
ne pas faire d' amalgame et à ne pas
remettre en cause l'utilité réelle du
sénat qui aujourd'hui n'est plus à
prouver
et pourtant ça fait partie des
revendications de certains
gilet jaune c'est le préfet qui réclame
la suppression du sénat ça doit faire
partie de ce grand débat cette question
institutionnelle selon vous à mon sens
non le grand débat un périmètre beaucoup
trop large pour donner finalement
quelque chose en dehors de son
organisation qui n'est pas encore très
clair je pense que le sénat est trop
méconnu et qu'on aurait besoin d'abord
avant de mettre ça sur la table
d'informer tous les citoyens sur le
travail du sénat je pense que c'est
essentiel et d'ailleurs dans tout ce qui
concerne le débat comment débattre quand
tout un chacun n'a pas les éléments pour
pouvoir débattre justement alors je suis
surpris parce qu'on a une présidence
verticale du autant bob et le présent
redécouvre aujourd'hui les sushis la
république que j'appellerais mois les
maires alors on a une
le départ du la présentielle uniquement
vers le sommet et on n'a pas eu ce
rapport avec la population c'était le la
cassure et le sénat sur l'importance ne
serait ce que par une petite chose si
vous avez écouté si elle peut le rejet
de l'autre finances 2010 9 sur un vote
c'est nord pour le rejet des tables de
carburant on serait peut-être pas là
mais c'est un peu un épiphénomène à
saissac a déclenché les choses mais
beaucoup plus important que ça mais on
n'écoute pas c'est le sénat on a eu deux
députés compter dans l'action mais
l'action un peu déconnecté je pense que
le sénat depuis le début a été
temporisateurs on peut le redevenir
aussi sur la loi anti casseurs sont les
précurseurs de leurs fins de promotions
cathy rocher et maintenant on la remet
dans le circuit à l'assemblée nationale
donc il ferait bien d'écouter un peu
plus nokia du temps de recul et canalise
les choses n'ont pas toujours le temps
des députés on voit mais peut-être dans
la pensée cette question de la révision
constitutionnelle est ce que c'est une
façon aussi bien de m probablement
c'est à mon avis l'un l'une des façons
d'échapper aux vraies questions
je crois qu'ils manuel macron a bien
compris que compte tenu de l'état des
finances de notre pays
il aurait bien du mal à répondre aux
questions liées au pouvoir d'achat qui
sont essentielles et à mon avis veut
donner là une espèce de caution aux
citoyens en mettant quelque chose
d'assez populaire finalement
comme la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires or on voit bien que tout
cela aura ses limites
je pense que l'une l'une des principales
revendications des gilet jaune
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas assez prise en
compte à mon sens c'est la fracture
territoriale et aujourd'hui cette
fracture territoriale et bien c'est le
sénat qui l'expriment en étant le
représentant des territoires et des élus
donc voilà je pense que les citoyens ont
aussi besoin de cette proximité est
cette démocratie représentative dont les
sénateurs font pleinement partie non
j'avais prévu eh bien je vais dans le
même sens un bien sûr nous sommes
l'assemblée des territoires
nous oeuvrons pour les territoires
peut-être puisque nous sommes élus par
les élus nous n'avons pas suffisamment
de nous communiquons peut-être pas assez
à ce niveau là moi j'ai rencontré les
gilet jaune et je les ai fortement
surpris en leur indiquant ce que nous
avions voté au sénat notamment sur le
projet de loi de finances il était très
surpris
donc peut-être il nous faudrait
communiquer davantage en tout cas pour
ma part je pense que on a paramètres la
réforme institutionnelle et à nous mêler
comme ça au détour d'une phrase à nous
mettre presque en victime expiatoire de
de tous ces événements c'est enfin pour
moi c'est c'est grave parce que ça doit
être la ville puisque vous parlez de
cette révision constitutionnelle vous
propose d'écouter la réponse du
président du sénat ce matin je le disais
lors de ses voeux à la presse
parlementaire on écoule gérard larcher
le référendum et modes de consultation
prévue par la constitution et un mode de
consultation que je ne récuse nullement
mes articles ans prévoit d un ensemble
de dispositifs et des questions
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
la révision du traité n'étant pas
constitutionnelle l'organisation
économique social et environnemental
mais l'article 11 n'est pas une voix de
révision de la constitution
donc si à l'issue du débat le président
de la république décide consulter les
français pourra les consulter sur un
certain nombre de questions dans les
formes prévues par les textes qu en ce
qui concerne la révision de la
constitution
d'ailleurs c'est le dernier chapitre
article 89 le titre ça s'appelle de la
révision et oui et donc pour être
extrêmement temps gelé dit au président
et je lui ai posé la question aussi
direct est ce que votre déclaration du
congrès sur je crois au bicamérisme bien
aujourd'hui vous en affranchissez m'a
dit non il m'a dit non il n'est pas
question de fusion dans ma tête entre le
conseil économique social et
environnemental et le sénat et si
devait-elle une proposition elle ne
pourrait passer que par l'article 89
c'est moi qui a ajouté ça aura pas de
fusion a été visible ont confirmé par
emmanuel macron à gérard larcher
malgré tout il ya toujours cette menace
d'un référendum qui plaira entendu
l'opposition très fort weedon en train
de communes du ma collègue reporter le
débat sur une question sociale et
fiscale sur le nombre d'élus et la
démocratie a un coût
même cru ainsi un coup on sera perçue
aujourd'hui justement qui a pu assez de
gens de terrain pour remonter des
informations on peut mettre moins de
début du mois deux sénateurs et on leur
en commun de connexion que le terrain
c'est pas ça le problème
le problème c'est répondent aux gens et
de faire son travail je pense que les
palmes les parlementaires font leur
travail
vous montez un petit peu moins voyez
s'empêcheront leva la marge ce n'est pas
un problème mais le vrai problème c'est
de prendre les racines locales et fait
remonter la fonction pour faire des lois
plus juste et plus correct pour les gens
et si on met moins de sénateur et mac
parlementaire bernanke en moins drôle
est que la population
le principe de cette émission on
retrouve ça me fera nuit salle des
conférences avec le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat patrick kanner alors
que on vient de l'apprendre cette
information est confirmée par l' agence
france-presse
alexandre benalla et on garde à vue mais
effectivement nous allons d'abord parler
de la sphère alexandre benalla
puisqu'alexandre benalla on vient de
l'apprendre est en garde à vue a
notamment sur le volet bien sûr de ces
passeports diplomatiques votre réaction
est ce que les travaux de la commission
denquête peuvent se poursuivre et
notamment comment que va-t-il se passer
avec son audition prévue lundi la
commission des requêtes a toujours prévu
d entendre monsieur ban a aimé chaque
race de lundi après midi nous verrons
bien dans quelle situation nous serons
au moment venu
par contre vu l'accélération des
événements et des informations qui sont
obtenues depuis 48 heures il ya cette
décision de justice ne m'étonne pas mais
je ne commande pas à lui paraît tout de
même justifié après les révélations que
l'on a pu entendre hier après midi je
n'ai pas commenter séparation des
pouvoirs vous le voudrez bien lâché
devant la commission dont il ya une
logique hier il ya une logique notamment
utilisation de fonds tel que l'a déclaré
patrick strzoda mais monsieur benalla
pourra s'expliquer
c'est aussi l'objet d'une garde à vue
c'est permettre à toute personne de
pouvoir se justifier et de donner
éventuellement des contre-arguments une
question sur peut-être ce
dysfonctionnement des administrations
entre le ministère des affaires
étrangères le ministère de l'intérieur
on a vu toutes les difficultés qu'il y
avait bien pour pouvoir tracer un
passeport diplomatique pour pouvoir
l'empêcher de passer une frontière ça
paraissait impossible à ce que nos
visites manifestement des trous dans la
raquette du fonctionnement de l'état
reconnu d'ailleurs un meilleur très
honnête par nos deux ministres qui ont
été auditionnés ce qui vous montre aussi
anomalie et puis et puis simplement
montré encore une fois que si tout
d'abord la presse n'avait pas fait du
bon travail et vous l'avez fait en
l'occurrence par ces informations et si
le sénat n'avait pas à nouveau réuni sa
commission denquête et bien n'en serions
pas là aujourd'hui donc bravo au sénat
puisque la semaine nationale et sa
majorité n'a pas voulu aller plus loin
dans son investigation
ah c'est une transition toute trouvée
nous allons également pas de la
conférence de presse de gérard larcher
ce matin qui a lui aussi a défendu le
bicamérisme on l'a senti très agacé
presque déçu par cette lettre français
adressée par emmanuel macron où il est
question de la transformation la réforme
voire la suppression du sénat
si mes informations sont bonnes gérard
larcher n'a pris cette petite phrase sur
le sénat qu'au moment de la parution de
la lettre
je n'ai pas très envie dire amicale en
tout cas bien c'est en cavalier de la
part des exécutifs quand je le regrette
je pense que les relations sont telles
qu'elles n'auraient pu être un peu plus
loyale sur le sujet et même si monsieur
macron se défend de vouloir fusionner
ses oeufs et le sénat le fait de l'avoir
écrit dans la lettre montre qu'on se
demande quel est le présent la
république
quel est le monsieur macron de la lettre
aux français qu'est ce que feint
attention au double langage et le sénat
ne mérite pas ce type de traitement un
petit peu je envie de dire olé olé pour
être assez vulgaire qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé bien de la prestation des
manuels macron devant les maires
plusieurs longues ou le présent de la
république et à mouiller la chemise est
ce que quelque part il n'a pas sauvé le
lancement du grand débat avec ses
prestations c'est une performance
physique intellectuel manifeste cette
heure avec les maires dont plus de trois
heures de l'intervention personnelle
voilà c'est remarquable il faut le il
faut le dire ce qui ne m'étonne pas
même macron était le ministre de
françois hollande je les ai connus dans
ce cadre et je puis vous dire que
manifestement il en est capable
après la question c'est est-ce que c'est
un début de campagne est ce qu'il a
commencé sa campagne trois ans et demi
avant la fin de son mandat on peut
s'interroger en l'occurrence est pas que
moi sur le sujet donc et maintenant
attendons le déroulement du débat et
surtout ses conclusions très rapidement
votre avis sur le non cumul des mandats
ce qu'il faut relancer le débat là
dessus
gérard larcher est favorable il juge
qu'il ya un problème de déconnexion des
élus aujourd'hui à emmanuel macron n'est
pas contre pour les très petites je ne
suis pas toujours en désaccord qui gère
larcher mais là oui je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de déconnexion savez moi je suis un
élu du nord
je tiens mes permanences toutes les
semaines je suis sur le terrain dans les
villes de mon département et elles sont
nombreuses 650 je ne me sens pas du tout
déconnecté c'est une question de
conception de la manière dont on fait
son travail sur le terrain un sénateur
ou un député qui fait son travail dans
sa circonscription où qu'elles soient
départementales ou locales et bien n'est
pas déconnecté ni de la population et
des élus locaux
merci beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir
répondu à mes questions c'est la
question du non cumul des mandats qui
est revenu également dans le débarras
gérard larcher aurait eu une
conversation sur ce non cumul avec le
chef de l'état qui s'est dit visiblement
ouvert aussi un débat sur ce non cumul
et le froid de nouveau autorisé les
parlementaires à cumuler un mandat local
c'est via noël ou en tout cas il
faudrait au moins pour le sénat devoir
exiger qu'un sénateur est
obligatoirement occuper un mandat local
avant d'exercer pour moi c'est l'essence
même
de la fonction du sénateur je vois pas
comment on peut représenter les
collectivités les élus sans savoir ce
qu'ils vivent au quotidien
j'ai été moi-même maire d'une commune
rurale pendant dix ans et cette
expérience a été ma meilleure école de
vie et aujourd'hui cette expérience
nourrie véritablement ma fonction de
sénatrice
après je je n'aurais pas été contre de
la conserver bien au contraire même si
comme comme l'indiquait notre collègue
tout à l'heure moi aussi je suis sur le
terrain en permanence mais il n'empêche
une fois qu'on est sorti de cette
fonction d'élu local et bien la
connexion avec la réalité beaucoup plus
difficile en place par la gauche 11le
préville ça serait super alors de
revenir sur cette question et bien moi
je partage évidemment l'opinion de
patrick kanner
cela dit moi je reste j'étais adjointe
donc je reste conseiller municipal d'une
commune rurale
je suis encore délégués communautaires
dans une communauté de communes donc
j'ai encore le pied et je suis d'accord
aussi avec le fait qu' on a besoin de
cette expérience pour pouvoir exercer et
j'irai mais j'irai même plus loin un
mandat de député je ne vois pas comment
on peut être parlementaire si on n'a pas
été du local
c'est une expérience absolument
indispensable à mon sens sans pouvoir
les parlementaires à plein temps qu'il
ne soit pas connaître oui mais on
pourrait au moins l'exception pour les
petites et moyennes communes après je
veux une très grosse commune ou prison
de conseils généraux régionaux et
départementaux régionaux c'est compliqué
mais dans une petite commune au moins
l'ancrage local est utile et qu'il est
l'expérience est importante
on voit d'ailleurs la déconnexion qu'il
ya eu aujourd'hui avec les élus qui sont
arrivés au parlement n'ayant pas ces
espaces ne connaissait pas le terrain et
le présente et revient vers les mers
pour faire se référant à une façon c'est
de ce grand débat public il se sert des
mères il ya très peu de temps il était
détaché des maires il avait enlevé les
dotations les emplois jeunes est ce
qu'il y aura une dotation pour les mères
qui vont recevoir dans la queue mourir
leur mairie qui vont aller coûte qui ont
les clés rage chauffage pro soient leurs
couleurs leurs habitants leurs
concitoyens
non donc amender on a un président que
très attachés du local et maintenant il
revient vers le local parce qu'il en a
besoin
dans d'autres on peut pas à ce débat
très important mais font pas que soient
comptés comme l'a dit patrick kanner ce
sera les réponses rapportant ce que le
débat peut la voir on peut faire du
théâtre on peut faire tout ce que l'on
veut on peut faire de la mise en scène
pendant sept heures qui sera important
c'est quelle réponse apporter aux gens
qui étaient au rond-point des bas les
maires vont organiser ça se met en place
signe annuel ce n'est pas évident encore
là la semaine dernière visiblement tout
le monde se range derrière cette une
veillée de grands débats et vous le
rappeliez les élus sont prêts à ouvrir
les portes de leur mairie pour organiser
ces débats oui je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on a affaire quand même un président qui
avoue clairement son inaptitude à
répondre aux demandes ou aux attentes
des français et il leur demande
maintenant de s'exprimer
enfin j'ai envie de dire enfin
maintenant le rôle des maires comme
l'exprimé mon collègue
effectivement aujourd'hui ils
redécouvrent les bières les bienfaits
les vertus de la démocratie de proximité
et puis des élus locaux qui sont les
premiers transmetteur donc moi
j'encourage évidemment les maires à
mettre en oeuvre les moyens matériels
pour l'organisation et la bonne tenue de
ces débats maintenant il me semble hors
de question que ces mères en question
soient les organisateurs et les
animateurs de ces débats en jalles
préville arrive à moi à mon sens je veux
dire le problème qu'on a actuellement
c'est un problème qui a été créée par
qui en quelque sorte a été générée par
l'attitude du gouvernement
principalement et c'est vrai qu'on
demande maintenant au maire d'organiser
donc bon organisons les débats certes
mais ce qui pour moi est le plus
important c'est que va-t-on faire de
tout cela est d'abord qui va venir
participer à ces débats
est ce que saura valeur une certaine
valeur justement puisque on l'a entendu
certains gilet jaune ne viendront pas
donc cette consultation se détend les
français
mais bien sûr qu'on sait c'est ouvert
mais justement ça aurait été bien qu'il
vienne aussi quelque part après moi ce
qui m'interpelle plus c'est la synthèse
qui va être fait et c'est surtout la
près que va-t-on faire de tout ce qu'on
a et calais la transparence et qu'elle
est l'indépendance de ceux qui vont
collecter on sait déjà annoncé pascal
perrineau
quand on est bien ici le politologue
comme observateur dont l'organisation de
ce débat dany la tablette on sent bien
que les élus à la fois ils veulent
peut-être bien ouvrir les portes de
leurs mérites pas question en revanche
de porter peut-être les cheveux la
responsabilité de l'échec
je mets en garde edi locaux je
recruterai sur l'étal écoute une patte
animateurs parce qu'il faut pas besoin
maintenant leurs proches à eux ils ne
l'ont fait que transmettre les doléances
auprès de leur public d'être responsable
de janeiro et de non réponse c'est le
danger qui se présente pour nous élus
locaux le gros souci qu'il ya une partie
qui dit non moi je participe au jeu
laisse un cahier à disposition et je
transmets mes à des hummer qui
s'engagent et tout le bravo je dis bravo
de s'engager mais faut pas que ça leur
revienne derrière en disant voilà comme
n'y a pas de réponse et vous monsieur le
maire je suis venu voir un peu comme ils
viennent nous voir une permanence quoi
c'est le gros danger
alors là on retrouve quand même quelque
chose qui est paradoxal c'est qu'on a
quelqu'un qui est parti en campagne qui
avait un programme mais qu'il
connaissait même pas la fin des français
alors on peut partir sur le la
réservation de la dette à outrance aller
vite mais c'était un peu trop vite et
aujourd'hui un décrochage complètement
des citoyens et qui peut être dangereux
puisqu'on parle de jeunes qui
participent même pas jc de ces gens
irresponsables puisque ils ne veulent
même pas participé à un débat et à cela
je envie de leur dire mais allez-y pour
causer des torts aux points à manifester
vous avez bloqué vous demandiez à la
parole vous l'avez profitez-en
sur le plateau de public sénat je vous
laisse regagné l'hémicycle puisque la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement va débuter dans quelques
instants on retrouve là ne sera ni vais
toujours au salle des conférences avec
la sénatrice socialiste de paris marie
pierre de la gontrie alors que je le
rappelle c'est l'information principale
aujourd'hui bien c'est cette garde à vue
d'alexandre bénin
effectivement votre réaction à cette
garde à vue d'alexandre benalla on l'a
appris
il y à quelques minutes dans et bien la
faire désormais des passeports
diplomatiques
est-ce que cela va impacter les travaux
de la commission d' enquête sur vous ça
il est un petit peu tôt pour le dire
puisque nous l'avons convoqué lundi
après midi
donc de ce point de vue ça ne devrait
pas impacter les travaux de la
commission denquête non ce qui est
intéressant c'est que effectivement ce
sujet qui a été encore une fois mis à
jour par la presse est éclairé par la
commission d' enquête du sénat donc
voilà deux institutions sans qui cette
affaire n'aurait jamais été révélée au
grand jour tout cela progresser est
incontestablement très sérieux nous
avons entendu hier le directeur de
cabinet du président la république qui
nous a dit des choses ces surprenantes
oui patrick est affirmative nombre de
bombes hier autour du nombre de voyages
effectués avec les passeports
diplomatiques par alexandre benalla une
vingtaine et puis surtout et bien cette
falsification de papiers à en tête pour
pouvoir obtenir un passeport de service
auprès du ministère de l'intérieur était
très étonnant me semble utile c'était
qu'il était très affirmatif c'est un
haut fonctionnaire un serviteur de
l'état il ne parle pas impunément la
connais beaucoup plus d'ombré dans l'été
dernier oui et puis bon c'est quelqu'un
qui est très sérieux c'est un voilà un
grand serviteur de l'état
donc effectivement il nous indique
alexandre d'ennahda auraient utilisé une
vingtaine de fois ce passeport sans que
semble-t-il c'est un petit peu plus
étranges les services français que ce
soit de l'intérieur du quai d'orsay
n'ont eu connaissance là on a trouvé
jean yves le drian un tout petit peu
plus mal à l'aise par rapport à cela
les anomalies entre le ministère de
l'intérieur oui alors des explications
informatique
bon très bien un manque de curiosité
incontestable parce que qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas lexandre benalla à
naqoura que le sénat qui si la soirée
et puis on sait que la présence
d'alexandre benalla au tchad les 5 et 6
décembre était révélée par une lettre
confidentielle qui est lu par toutes les
personnes qui s'intéressent à cette pays
d'une lettre du continent révéré cette
présence le 12 décembre d'ailleurs jean
yves le drian lui même dit un avion
privé de standing sur les reporte
djamena ne passe pas inaperçu pour
autant jean yves le drian nous a dit
n'avoir été informé qu'après le 24
décembre
en fait après la sortie dans la presse
française l'article de l'article du
monde de la présence d'alexandre benalla
et à ce moment là seulement interrogeant
l'ambassadeur qui lui-même reconnaissait
avoir oublié le prévenir bref on est
dans quelque chose qui est si on est
gentil une organisation de pieds
nickelés
si on est plus suspicieux dans quelque
chose on n'est pas totalement sûr que ce
soit la réalité en tout cas pour revenir
à la question de la garde à vue
il y a au minimum une commande ya une
accumulation de passeport
un usage qui n'est pas conforme à la
commande à la réglementation puisque il
n'était plus en poste je parle
d'élection benalla est par ailleurs et
là dessus nous n'avons pas d'éléments
pour pour l'établir les propos de
patrick strzoda indiquant que cela avait
été établi à partir d'un document qui
n'était pas authentique étaient en lice
a sous sa responsabilité
mais ce n'est pas n'importe qui qui
parle donc forcément une garde à vue en
tout cas une interrogation de benalla
semble le minimum
merci beaucoup marie pierre de la
gontrie d'avoir répondu à mes questions
nous allons tout de suite rejoindre et
bien l'hémicycle où se trouvait
alexandre touzard bonjour à quel est
l'ordre du jour de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement alexandre et
bien tam ces questions d'actualité vont
porter essentiellement sur le grand
débat national qui a été lancé
officiellement cette semaine après l
échange des manuels macron pendant sept
heures avec plus de 600 mer en normandie
et ce qui préoccupe les sénateurs dans
ce grand débat national c'est notamment
la réforme des institutions puisque
emmanuel macron dans sa lettre aux
français en début de semaine a remis en
question le rôle du sénat et jara
larcher ce matin en conférence de presse
a défendu le rôle du sénat et
l'importance du bicamérisme dans l'
équilibre d
institutions de la vème république et il
a même rendu public les extraits de son
entretien avec emmanuel macron en début
de semaine à l'élysée gérard larcher a
affirmé que pour emmanuel macron il ne
s'agissait pas de fusionner le sénat et
le conseil économique social et
environnemental
et puis autour de ce grand débat
national il aura des questions sur les
pistes cas ouvert emmanuel macron
notamment au sujet des territoires il a
affirmé qu'il était ouvert à des
aménagements sur la nouvelle limitation
de vitesse de 80 km heure et également
sur la réforme territoriale la loi notre
qui avait été opéré en 2015 sous
françois hollande
et puis les sénateurs vont interroger le
gouvernement sur les modalités
d'organisation de ce grand débat
national et sur son indépendance
on sait depuis cette semaine que ce sont
deux ministres sébastien lecornu et
emmanuelle wargon qui vont piloter ce
grand débat et il y aura cinq garant de
l'indépendance de ce débat et on a
appris ce matin que le président du
sénat gérard larcher a nommé pascal
perrineau le politologue comme
observateur de ce grand débat national
et puis dans ces questions d'actualité
il y aura beaucoup de questions sur les
gilet jaune sur la liberté de la presse
sur les violences policières également
sur les effets de ce mouvement sur les
petits commerces qui fragilise
l'économie avec beaucoup de petits
patrons qui sont obligés de mettre au
chaud masqué au chômage partiel
certains de leurs salariés et puis on
aura également une question sur la
hausse des tarifs d'autoroutes
on entend la cloche c'est le début de
ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
temps d'observation et le procès verbal
et donc si je n'en vois points adoptées
sur les sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues se renouvelle pour chaque il
ne sera qu'un d'entre vous mes meilleurs
voeux pour cette année qui commence
aussi à vous remercier tous ceux que
vous m'avez adressées qui sont en cours
de lecture mais qui sont nombreux et et
chaleureux notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise sur public
sénat bien sûr sont des sites et au nom
du cdh 1 comme à l'accoutumée on prend
des résolutions pour 2019
le temps des voeux c'est que nous soyons
essentiel
j'avais dit attaché aux valeurs
essentielles du sénat le respect et des
uns et des autres et naturellement de
respect du temps de parole qui est
peut-être plus prosaïque mais aussi
important la parole est au président
jean marc gabouty pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
premier ministre l'année 2018 aurait été
marquée par l'irruption des gilets
jaunes mouvement social inédit au départ
spontané et qui témoigne d'un profond
malaise notre société qu'elles soient
légitimes et généreuse souvent
contradictoires aux réalistes et parfois
provocatrices des revendications
exprimées doivent être écoutés toutefois
elle ne sera en aucun cas justifier le
déferlement de violence de menaces
d'invectivés et de dégradations qu'a
subi notre pays depuis mi novembre
le bilan humain dramatique de dix morts
et de plus de 2500 blessés devraient un
peu plus interrogées les acteurs de ce
mouvement et ceux qui l'ont soutenu avec
parfois un objectif malsain de
récupération je tiens ici au nom du
groupe rdse a renouvelé tous nos
remerciements et notre soutien aux
forces de l'ordre aux personnels de
santé et aux services d'urgences
fortement sollicités pendant cette
période
sur le plan économique et social cet
épisode a flétri l'image donc
l'attractivité de notre pays et était
destructeur d'activité et d'emploi
au-delà des mesures très significative
10 milliards d'euros que vous avez
annoncé qu'ils ont été votés courant
décembre par l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat le débat national engagé
avant-hier va s'enrichir de propositions
concernant en particulier la démocratie
de proximité les services publics et la
fiscalité et le pouvoir d'achat
ce grand débat mme may suscité beaucoup
d'espoir il ne faudra pas décevoir à
côté de réformes structurelles plus
longue à mettre en place des mesures
concrètes d'application immédiate seront
attendus par nos concitoyens
comment visible envisagez-vous d'y
répondre
dans quels domaines possibles et avec
quel calendrier est pensée ou associer
le parlement particulier le sénat
représentant des territoires à
l'élaboration de ces mesures et de ses
réformes en amande un examen strictement
législatives des projets de loi je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole et
au ministre en charge des relations avec
le parlement monsieur marc feydeau
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gabouty devant vous remercier
de votre question qui permet d'en de ces
questions au gouvernement de porter un
certain nombre d'éclairages vous me
posez la question de l'association
finalement des parlementaires et
singulièrement du sénat au grand débat
national qui va s'ouvrir
vous avez raison de dire d'abord je
crois qu'il peut susciter il va sans
doute susciter un certain un grand
espoir pour un certain nombre de gens
qui cherchent des solutions qui pose un
certain nombre de questions et de
problèmes et auquel il va falloir
répondre
peut-être vous répondent en trois temps
le premier temps c'est le temps du débat
qui est en train de s'ouvrir j'aurais
salué l'initiative d'un certain nombre
de parlementaires au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale
deux responsables de groupes qui ont dit
qu'il s'associerait au débat avec les
divergences qui sont à l'intérieur de ce
débat pour faire en sorte que les
français puissent se saisir des
questions qui leur sont soumises et se
saisir peut-être pour un certain nombre
d'entre d'autres questions et pour faire
en sorte que les parlementaires puissent
aussi être les témoins vigilant et les
porte parole d'une certaine façon de ce
qui va se dire ici
la deuxième chose dire aussi que le
premier ministre adressée aux présidents
des deux assemblées un courrier pour
créer un comité de suivi et permettre à
chaque groupe politique puisqu'il s'agit
bien d'affaires politiques de pouvoir
suivre les débats et s'approprier
également le débat la troisième chose et
c'était peut-être plus haut font encore
la question que vous me posiez et que
vous ne posiez c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils aient une traduction législative
et au moment où parfois la démocratie
représentative est mise en doute en
particulier parfois parce qu'ils
manifestent
il est bon aussi que la démocratie
représentative à la fois dans le travail
préalable c'est à dire dans le débat
mais aussi dans la suite c'est à dire le
travail législatif puisse se saisir des
questions et donc c'est ce qui se fera
au travers des textes qui seront
examinés il ya des textes qui sont déjà
sur la table et à les textes pour
lesquels nous avons décidé d'aménager le
calendrier je pense à la révision
constitutionnelle ou d'autres textes et
sur lequel il faudra peut-être
l'enrichir et probablement l'enrichir
des débats qui ont lieu
et puis peut-être des textes qui
naîtront du débat tel qu'il est en train
de se nouer sur les territoires et c'est
donc bien l'articulation entre le débat
qui doit se jouer
et puis la deuxième chose qui ait la
capacité que nous aurons à traduire et
vous avez raison de dire il ya des
solutions de long terme il faudra le
dire parce qu'il ya parfois des
solutions de long terme et parfois des
solutions de court terme c'est bien dans
ce cadre là que se déroulera le débat
merci monsieur la parole est à notre
collègue esther benbassa pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur
mutilé éborgné défiguré subissons
quotidiennement la violence symbolique
et sociales imposées par les politiques
gouvernementales c'est désormais dans
leur chair que sont frappées de nombreux
gilet jaune face à cette crise majeure
et à des rassemblement protestataire qui
ne sont celles pas exemple parfois de
violence l'unique réponse apportée par
l'exécutive est une répression
disproportionnée plus de 5600
interpellations et gardes à vue plus de
mille condamnations ont le sens environ
mille blessés dont 94 grave les
violences policières vont crescendo avec
l' usage d'armes toujours plus
dangereuse grenades de désencerclement
flash ball et autres lbd40 sans oublier
le tabassage et le gazage
quasi-systématique dernier ben c'est
vrai c'est vous c'est que ça vous énerve
voilà derniers corps dernier cas en date
vous vous taisez quand même non bon
dernier cas en date olivier père de
famille de 47 ans pompier volontaire
manifestant pacifiquement avec son
épouse le 12 janvier à bordeaux
touché à la tête par un tir de flashball
il est dans le coma
quand on sait qu en principe seuls les
torses et les membres inférieurs peuvent
être visés par les policiers depuis
l'acte du 1 du mouvement des gilet jaune
l'igpn a été saisie de 200 cas de
violences policières soit 118 font
actuellement l'objet d'une enquête
interne
ma question est simple
n'est-il pas temps de mettre un terme à
cette répression d'une brutalité
intolérable et d'interdire comme le
préconise le défenseur des droits
l'utilisation d'armes non létales par
les forces de l'ordre pour vous répondre
les paroles et/ou secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur avait
la parole monsieur d'ulysse monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice benbassa
d'abord le contexte je tiens à rappeler
le contexte dans lequel se déroulent les
manifestations auxquelles vous faites
allusion un contexte de manifestations
qui ne sont jamais déclarait jamais
encadré avec des manifestants qui va
parfois mais très souvent s'en prennent
de manière extrêmement violente et
agressive aux policiers en leur jetant
divers projectiles et beaucoup nous
disent qu'ils ont le sentiment plutôt
qu'on cherche à les tuer c'est dans ce
contexte là que s'organise et qui est
prévue la riposte policière comme la
sénatrice et uniquement dans ce contexte
là quand il ya des agressions ou quand
il s'agit de disperser d attroupement
violent et ce contexte il est
extrêmement encadrées et vous le savez
très bien
la riposte des policiers elle est
toujours proportionnée elle se fait avec
ce qu'on appelle des armes
intermédiaires dont les conditions
d'utilisation sont très encadrées très
contrôlé très surveillé
ce ne sont pas 200 plaintes dont a été
saisi l'igpn mais ce sont 80 une enquête
judiciaire qui ont été ouvertes pour des
suspicions de violences policières
donc il y à bien un contrôle qui est
exercée la riposte elle s'effectue de
manière proportionnée mais face à de
véritables agressions dont sont le
les forces de l'ordre alors même alors
même qu'elles sont là pour nous protéger
pour protéger ces manifestations et je
vous le dis les manifestantes un
comportement qui est extrêmement violent
et c'est cette riposte là qui s'organise
alors vous parlez des moyens
intermédiaire vous parler des moyens
intermédiaire de défense effectivement
les policiers utilisent des grenades
lacrymogènes des grenades de
désencerclement et parfois quand ils
sont vraiment acculé le lanceur de
balles de défense
mais encore une fois dans des conditions
très strictes et nous avons rappelé avec
christophe castaner à l'ensemble des
policiers ces conditions d usage et ses
conditions d'emploi et je peux vous dire
que si les policiers n'avaient pas ne
faisait pas usage de ses moyens de
défense peut-être que certains d'entre
eux auraient été lynchées comme nous
l'avons beaucoup vu nous avons beaucoup
vu des tentatives de l'unss alger
membres des forces de l'ordre
et ça ça n'est pas acceptable et c'est
ça que nous voulons que vous condamniez
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est au président patrick
kanner pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre nous voulons donc dans
le grand débat lancé par le président de
la république
et comme nous l'avons déjà dit
publiquement les parlementaires
socialistes prendront toute leur part
dans ce débat sur le terrain dans les
communes
nous sommes de fervents défenseurs du
dialogue et du débat politique avec les
français nous redirons à cette occasion
les propositions que nous vous avons
déjà fait et que vous n'avez
malheureusement pas suivi
seulement il est une proposition dont
nous ne savons plus si nous aurons le
droit de la formule et je veux bien sûr
parler du rétablissement de l'usf
le président de la république a soufflé
le chaud et le froid sur ce point qui
devons nous croire le président de la
lettre aux français qui exclut toute
remise en cause de sa ligne économique
et social ou le président du débat en
normandie qui ouvre le droit de parler
de l' isf ce sujet d'edf pose plus
largement la question de la prise en
compte de la parole des français dans ce
débat à l'image de vos recule contre un
sur une partie de l'augmentation de la
csg pour les retraités sur la taxe
carbone sur le coup de pouce au smic via
la prime d'activité sur vos 80 km/heure
désormais entendez-vous infléchir votre
politique économique et sociale si
contestée où ce débat ne sera-t-il qu'un
exercice de communication sans suite
enfin monsieur premier ministre
permettez moi une dernière question
comment envisagez vous la conclusion de
ce grand débat accepterez-vous comme
vous l'ont demandé certains syndicats
que la fin du grand débat prenne la
forme d'une vraie négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux que vous avez
négligé jusqu'ici on a parole
et avancer le premier minis sur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président caennais
vous m'interrogez sur le grand débat son
organisation le sens qu'il peut avoir la
porte et qu'il aura et ses conclusions
au plus exactement la méthode retenue au
terme de ce grand débat et un certain
nombre de questions sur lequel je peux
parfaitement vous répondre ce débat est
organisé pendant les deux mois qui
viennent pour faire en sorte que chacun
tous les français où qu'ils vivent et ça
compte
quel que soit leur âge leurs occupations
professionnelles leur statut puisse
s'exprimer
vous savez comme moi monsieur le
président que il est déraisonnable
d'imaginer interdire aux français de
s'exprimer que si on leur si on les
invitait à ne parler que d'un sujet il
aurait toute liberté toute latitude pour
s'exprimer sur l'ensemble des sujets
qu'ils veulent voix évoquée vous le
savez je le sais aussi et c'est parce
que nous le savons que le président de
la république a souhaité cadre est entre
guillemets le débat non pas pour faire
de tel ou tel sujet des sujets qui
serait tabou c'est à dire qu'on ne
pourrait pas évoqué mais pour dire quel
est le cadre dans lequel nous allons
prendre en compte ce que diront les
français
prenons un exemple qui parce qu'il sera
évident montrera la logique
imaginez ce que je ne crois pas ce que
je n'espère pas évidemment que les
français veuillent mettre en cause la
forme républicaine de nos institutions
je ne crois pas qu'ils le feront même si
même si même si nous devons faire
attention à préserver ce qui nous semble
parfois acquis
imaginez qu'il le dise vous voyez bien
vous voyez bien monsieur le président
que nous ne nous engageons rions pas
dans cette logique c'est bien évident je
prends cet exemple et il est tellement
excessif que il vous indique que
clairement les choses
les éléments qui constituent le socle de
l'engagement du président de la
république au moment de l'élection aux
présidentielles qui constituent le socle
de l'engagement des parlementaires de la
majorité ont été acquis au moment d'une
élection
je pense que vous reconnaîtrez comme moi
qu'il ne peut pas enfin qu'ils ne
peuvent pas être écartés qu'il constitue
là aussi un des éléments qui font de la
confiance
un des éléments sur lequel cette
majorité que vous avez parfaitement le
droit de critiquer monsieur le sénateur
mais un des éléments sur lesquels cette
majorité s'est engagée et la légitimité
qui découlent de l'élection doit
évidemment aussi aussi être respectées
autrement dit monsieur le président un
certain nombre de questions ont été
posées beaucoup 35 ou 36 je crois le
directement par le président de la
république dans sa lettre qu'il a
adressée aux français en répondant à ces
questions en s'exprimant sur ces sujets
les français vous nous donner un certain
nombre d'indications
il appartiendra ensuite au gouvernement
au parlement à l'ensemble de ceux qui
concourent débat public d'en faire leur
miel de s'en inspirer dans la réponse
aux questions profondes et anciennes qui
taraude notre société c'est dans cet
esprit que nous nous engageons et vous
évoquez la question la proposition qui a
été formulée par certaines organisations
syndicales pas toutes mais certaines qui
était d'ailleurs reprise par certaines
associations d'élus d'organiser au terme
de l'exercice une grande conférence
territoriale et sociale qui permettrait
à l'ensemble des acteurs en question
d'échanger sur ce qui ressort du grand
débat et de le transformer le cas
échéant en propositions de solutions
c'est une bonne proposition
j'entends je pense que nous allons
lancer le débat que ce débat doit vivre
et qu'au fur et à mesure qu'il vivra
nous pourrons répondre à un certain
nombre de questions et de propositions
comme celle ci mais je crois monsieur le
président que si nous voulons être
logique
alors il faut faire en sorte que ceux
qui formulent l'ambition de participer
au terme du débat la définition des
solutions choisies ce d'une façon ou
d'une autre de participer aux débats
pendant qu'il a lieu sinon il y aurait
quelque chose de comment dirais-je
curieux à faire en sorte qu'on réclame
de participer à la fin mais qu'on ne
participe pas pendant le débat si ce
débat prospère comme comme nous le
souhaitons et comme je crois un très
grand nombre de français l'espère alors
peut-être faudra-t-il faire droit à
cette proposition
je crois qu'il est un peu tôt pour
répondre à cette question je pense qu'il
faut laisser aux débats le soin d'être
lancée en garantissant aux français ce
que nous avons fait ce que le président
de la république a dit ce que je redis
ici devant les sénateurs que nous
tiendrons compte des éléments qui sont
formulées à l'intérieur du cadre qui a
été proposée par le président de la
république monsieur le président en
colère
monsieur près ministre j'entends votre
réponse et je vous confirme que les
parlementaires socialistes participeront
à votre grand débat au grand débat
national qui a été lancé par le
président de la république la démocratie
participative peut être enrichie par la
démocratie participative représentative
pardon parce que j'ai du kwh à linverse
moi j'ai compris en tout cas la
démocratie participative ne peut pas se
substituer à la démocratie
représentative et je tiens à insister
sur le fait que nous défendrons bec et
ongles bicamérisme monsieur le premier
ministre
et que
et que naturellement le sénat le sénat
comme lanceur d'alert doit être
respectée et parfois vous pourriez être
bien inspiré à écouter ses conclusions
merci la parole est à jean louis
lagourgue
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires ont cher
collègue monsieur le président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur le
15 décembre dernier un navire de pêche
étaient interceptés au large de la
réunion avec à son bord près de 70
personnes dont des femmes et des enfants
tous originaires du sri lanka
quelques jours plus tard un autre bateau
accosté transportant cette fois sept
passagers et portant à cinq le nombre de
navires qui ont rejoint la réunion en
2018 en provenance et cette île voisine
de l'inde situé à 4200 km des côtes
réunionnaises
ces faits laissent penser qu'une
nouvelle filière est en train de se
structurer pour fuir la crise politique
ethnique et religieuse qui divise
l'ancien celle en dix ans après la fin
de la guerre civile causé la mort de
près de cent mille personnes
les mines minorité tamoule et christiane
reste en proie aux persécutions la
réunion représente une porte d'entrée
vers la france pays des droits de
l'homme où la diaspora sri lankaise
compte environ cent cinquante mille
personnes sur les quelques 4 80 migrants
qui ont rejoint la réunion en l'espace
de dix mois
certains ont formulé des demandes
d'asile d'autres ont déjà été reconduits
chez eux avec les conséquences que l'on
peut imaginer
au delà de nous alerter sur le drame
humain que vit cette population
l'ouverture de cette nouvelle voie
migratoire migratoire vers la réunion
suscite de vives inquiétudes de la
population
mais question monsieur le ministre sont
donc les suivantes les autorités
dispose-t-elle de moyens adéquats pour
assurer la surveillance des côtes
réunionnaises
quelle position le gouvernement compte
il adopter face à ce phénomène aussi
soudain qu'inattendu qui touche la
réunion et comment accompagner cette
population sans risquer une
amplification du flux migratoires je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et
secrétaire d'état auprès du matériel que
le rendu des turbines
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur donc
effectivement je vous confirme que
depuis le mois de mars de l'année
dernière nous avons enregistré l'arrivée
de quatre navires sur les côtes
réunionnaises donc avec un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont fait un
périple de plus de 4000 km en mer et
donc les autos les autorités françaises
à la réunion donc ont mis en place un
dispositif d'abord sanitaire d'accueil
de prise en charge
et puis un dispositif de prise en charge
administrative qui a effectivement
conduit à prendre en cours à prendre en
compte
parfois des demandes d'asile parfois ce
sont des décisions de non admission qui
ont été prises et comme vous l'avez
souligné il y a eu également des
éloignements effectif auquel il a été
procédé la politique qui était mise en
oeuvre est une politique qui a visé
d'abord à renforcer la surveillance des
côtes comme vous le souhaitez bien
évidemment à la réunion mais aussi en
bien bien bien en aval de cela de
prendre contact avec les autorités du
sri lanka pour définir ensemble une
politique qui conduit aller à les
inciter à détecter des départs et ce
sont plusieurs navires qui ont été
empêchés de quitter le sri lanka pour se
rendre à la réunion donc c'était quelque
chose d'assez le positif et puis bien
évidemment cette politique nous allons
la poursuivre avec le sri lanka puisque
nous allons avoir une réunion avec les
autorités du sri lanka à la direction
générale des étrangers en france qui se
tiendra le 25 janvier pour aborder
précisément 7,7 c'est cette thématique
voyez bien que notre ambition il est à
la fois d'être protecteur du droit de
protection auquel en droit légitimement
un certain nombre de personnes mais en
même temps être également très ferme
pour éviter que ne se reconstitue une
filière d'immigration clandestine du sri
lanka vers la réunion et au final une
nouvelle filière de traite des êtres
humains
merci que la gauche merci la parole est
à notre collègue marc-philippe daubresse
pour le groupe l'est républicain
la parole monsieur le premier ministre
dans le livre révolution qu'il écrivait
juste avant d'être élu président de la
république
emmanuel macron disait ceci aujourd'hui
des français ont l'impression que leur
gouvernement ne gouverne plus le
rappeler partie les marchés des sondages
la rue il existe une confusion sur le
détenteur du pouvoir
quand il n'ya pas de clarté des
gouvernements le peuple se cabre il faut
savoir expliquer plutôt que de faire de
la communication
une nouvelle étape de la déconcentration
de l'état est nécessaire
je crois dans un nouveau partage
démocratique c'est le fondement de la
république contractuelle dont nous avons
besoin république qui fait confiance aux
territoires à la société et aux acteurs
pour se transformer les collectivités
locales et leurs élus doivent jouer un
rôle accru c'est une nouvelle étape de
transfert des pouvoirs vers ces
collectivités que nous vous devons
décider nous ne saurions mieux dire
monsieur le premier ministre au moment
où la crise des gis légende se traduit
par une rupture banale d'une rupture
brutale du lien de confiance entre le
peuple son président et son gouvernement
pouvez vous nous expliquer pourquoi
depuis deux ans le président de la
république a fait très exactement le
contraire de ce que préconisait le
candidat macron enr centralisant
outrance toujours plus et en rejetant le
rôle prééminent des mères que vous
reprenez subitement en considération
pouvez vous êtes vous pète enfin prêt à
mettre en oeuvre les conditions d'une
déconcentration de l'état comme voulu
comme on le disait ainsi qu'une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation massive et
d'expérimentation faisant confiance aux
élus locaux et aux partenaires sociaux
comme vous le demander dans les
conférences le président du sénat qui
est dans la constitution un garant de
l'équilibré des pouvoirs et des
territoires m'a fait vous prêt à changer
radicalement de méthode en insistant du
bas vers le haut et non plus du haut
vers le bas pour éviter que votre grand
débat ne se transforme en grande des
bacs pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement
chez ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur daubresse
vous remercier de votre question parce
que ça permet au delà de la dcn lecture
qui sont les vôtres et des citations que
vous faites de peut-être redire et re
préciser ce qu'est la politique du
gouvernement et notamment dans le grand
débat à vrai dire on a vu d'ailleurs je
trouve un exercice mardi dernier avec le
président de la république avec les
maires qui était un exercice qui a
démontré pour ceux qui pouvaient en
douter y compris parmi certains
manifestants le rôle des maires leur
capacité à saisir la situation leur
territoire et être les représentants de
leur territoire le gouvernement depuis
qu'il est installé il a envoyé un
certain nombre de messages alors
peut-être n'ont-ils pas été assez perçu
le premier c'est la moto monsieur
daubresse vous avez été maire d'une
grande communion versa je suis j'ai été
maire d'une commune un peu plus au sud
de ce département et donc nous
partageons cette connaissance je crois
et c'est cet amour des territoires et
des collectivités locales et donc le
gouvernement avait décidé alors que
pendant les cinq années précédentes les
dotations avait baissé fortement de
stabiliser les dotations mais c'était un
signal c'est peut-être pas la question
mais c'était un signal de confiance qui
avaient été faits au tac aux
collectivités et aussi peut-être même si
ça a pu être mal perçu au travers de la
contractualisation la deuxième chose
c'est que le gouvernement essaie le
texte que nous aurons à débattre même
s'il a été reporté et le président la
république devant le congrès des maires
en 2017 avait indiqué qu'il souhaitait
qu'une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation sur pair avec le droit
à la différenciation quoi de mieux que
le droit à la différenciation pour
permettre aux collectivités de se saisir
des choses et puis le troisième point
parce que le président la république en
a parlé au maire nous étions plutôt
collectivement me semble-t-il y compris
dans les associations d'élus a pensé
qu'il fallait opérer une pause sur les
grandes réformes territoriales qui avait
donné un sentiment un peu de tourbillon
aux uns et aux autres
ceci étant à l'expérience et à
l'expérience que vous avez que nous
avons tous on voit bien qu'il ya une
question autour de la loi notre autour
des périmètres autour des compétences et
cela aussi le président de la république
a déclaré qu'il se déclarerait ouvert à
des débats des ajustements pas pour tout
refonder une fois de plus mais pour
répondre aux exigences pratiques des
mers et c'est bien ça qui sera l'enjeu
aussi du grand débat
merci sunrise oui messieurs min zhu
comprendre et au vu de ce que j'ai lu
qu'on preuve préfère les preuves d'amour
aux déclarations d'amour nous attendons
une grande conférence territoriale
après le grand débat et une grande
conférence sociale nous attendons une
loi de décentralisation et nous
attendons que vous mettiez en pratique
les choses en respectant le sénat qui
est quand même la première assemblée
désignée par la constitution pour
représenter les collectivités
territoriales
merci la parole est à notre collègue
vincent delahaye pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avait la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les français regardent les
sociétés d'autoroute avec suspicion
et pour cause si la qualité de service y
est globalement élevé les tarifs le sont
aussi
ce qui est inversement proportionnelle à
la transparence financière qui régissent
cet oligopole depuis les conditions de
privatisation très discutable de 2005
les mêmes opérateurs prétendent ne pas
gagner beaucoup d'argent
il nous en ferait presque pleuré et
pourtant ces sociétés ne savent pas quoi
inventer pour demander aux gouvernements
successifs d'allonger la durée de
concession
malheureusement l'état désargenté cède à
chaque fois aux mirages de travaux plus
ou moins utiles
réalisé par leurs propres filiales
contre quelques années encore de
punition tarifaire pour les
automobilistes
sans parler des turpitudes électoraliste
d'une ministres du précédent quinquennat
qui vont conduire à alourdir de nouveau
la facture dès le 1er février
à l'heure où les français veulent
retrouver du pouvoir d'achat exigent
plus de transparence
il est temps de faire la lumière sur
cette situation ces sociétés serait soit
disant prête à faire un geste
or nous ne connaissons pas les
conditions financières de ce geste
nous sommes donc pas capable d'apprécier
si l'effort est réel ou s'il s'agit
d'une aumône ou presque insultantes
le gouvernement étudie actuellement ses
propositions à partir de quel niveau les
jugera t-il acceptable
les sociétés d'autoroutes abandonneront
elle 20 30 ou 50 % des augmentations
prévues il semble aussi que leur
lobbying soit intense pour prendre en
charge de nouvelles sections d'autoroute
contre un allègement de la durée des
concessions qu en est-il pouvez-vous
nous assurer que les discussions seront
conduites sans opacité et en prenant en
compte la réelle situation financière de
ses sociétés pour vous répondre l'apport
l'écoville d'état maëlys de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur de rugy monsieur le ministre
d'état
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de l'est
nous partageons globalement votre
analyse et comme vous le savez les
sociétés d'autoroutes
les tarifs des sociétés d'autoroutes
tarifs des péages sont fixés par des
règles qui sont dans les contrats de
concessions d'autoroutes leers et ça ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui puisque la
première concession a été créée par une
loi de 1955 pour la société escota qui
gère notamment les autos dans le sud de
la france et par ailleurs en 2005
en effet les sociétés d'autoroutes qui
appartenait majoritairement à l'état ont
été privatisées ce qui à l'époque a
rapporté de l'argent à l'état mais ce
qui évidemment ne nous donne plus aucune
marge de manoeuvre pour renégocier les
contrats de ces sociétés
et si nous faisions des promesses
démagogiques et vous avez bien fait de
le rappeler et cognition français on va
pouvoir baisser les tarifs
et bien cela serait répercuté les années
suivantes et nous le payons encore
aujourd'hui ce qui a été fait en 2015 ou
en effet il ya eu une promesse
démagogique de baisse des tarifs et donc
se répercuter encore cette année les
automobilistes vont payer cette promesse
parce que c'est pas ce qu'ils font les
promesses qui paye ses les
automobilistes alors nous nous avons
demandé aux sociétés d'autoroutes de
faire des efforts sur la base de leurs
tarifs de leurs recettes et nous sommes
en train de négocier elisabeth bornes
ministre des transports auprès de moi
est actuellement à l'heure où je vous
parle en train de négocier avec les
sociétés d'autoroutes pour avoir des
tarifs notamment des abonnements les
automobilistes qui utilisent ces
autoroutes pour aller travailler tous
les jours il y en a un qui faisait des
abonnements avec de fortes réductions
sur cet usage
quotidien des autoroutes ce qui
permettra là un gain concrets pour un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes c'est
ça notre objectif et jeudi par ailleurs
que nous sommes totalement contre le
fait de prolonger encore plus ces
contrats que nous trouvons trop patent à
jeu pour les sociétés d'autoroutes
c'était la proposition des sociétés
d'autoroutes de faire un geste en
échange d'un allongement de durée
ce que nous refusons quelques secondes
oui monsieur le président j'aurais aimé
avoir la réponse sur ce qui paraissait
raisonnable au gouvernement pour
accepter ses propositions
en tout cas nous souhaitons nous dire
stop à la rentabilité maximale et stop à
la transparence minimale pour les
sociétés d'autoroutes
si la parole est à notre collègue
antoine karam pour le groupe de la
république en marche
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dimanche dernier dix neuf
kilos de cocaïne ont été retrouvés dans
les bagages d'une mère et de ses enfants
à l'art par félix éboué de cayenne alors
je vous le montre voilà le quotidien des
guyanais en quelques années seulement la
guyane terre d'amérique du sud est
devenue un espace majeur de transit vers
l'europe
imaginez qu entre 2014 et 2018
les saisies ont augmenté de 300 35 %
passant de 145 à 631 kg
si bien que selon l'observatoire
français des drogues et des toxicomanies
près de 30% du marché français évalué
entre 25 et 30 tonnes proviendrait de la
guyane très concrètement on compterait
20 à 30000 par avion soit plus de 3000
personnes par an et seulement 10%
interpellé à l'origine de ce trafic un
ennemi sans visage qui se cache derrière
le destin tragique de ces mules
transportant la drogue dans leurs
bagages
lorsqu'elle n'a cure gîte pas au péril
de leur vie les gens témoignent ici pour
l'avoir vécu pour avoir vu
une jeune femme mourir d'overdose en
plein vol sous les yeux de son fils
samuel sont toutes nos enfants les
proies faciles de trafiquants sans
scrupules qui puise dans le vivier des
jeunes inactifs
parce que la société n'est aujourd'hui
pas en mesure de leur proposer un emploi
de leur offrir un avenir
ces jeunes risquent volontiers leur vie
contre le mirage de quelques milliers
d'euros
monsieur le ministre je vous sais
préoccupé par ce sujet je sais aussi que
les autorités sont mobilisés conscient
de l'ampleur du phénomène
force est néamoins est néanmoins de
constater que les moyens de lutter les
tribunaux sont aujourd'hui saturés que
le trafic s'accroît considérablement
avec lui le nombre de ses victimes
alors je vous le demande solennellement
le gouvernement tente il déploya un plan
ambitieux de prévention et de lutte
contre le trafic de stupéfiants en
provenance de guyane je vous remercie
quand vous répondre la parole et de
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur le chauvinisme celui neige
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur carle sur le
constat d'abord vous avez raison le
trafic de stupéfiants en provenance de
la guyane est en augmentation
vous savez et vous l'avez rappelé que
c'est une des voies d'acheminement d'un
pays de provenance une département de
provenance de la cocaïne qui est importé
ici en france dont qui passent par ce
département et qui provient d'afrique
centrale et d'amérique centrale par dans
et d'amérique du sud
le constat il est là avec une
augmentation et des personnes qui
parfois exposent leur vie en
transportant in corpore comme on dit
après ingestion cette cocaïne et
l'augmentation est importante
ce que nous avons mis en oeuvre compte
tenu de cette augmentation exponentielle
et après que un groupe interministériel
se soient réunis avec les ministères
concernés l'intérieur la justice
solidarité et santé et
nous nous sommes réunis pour décider
trois mesures
d'abord le renforcement significatif des
contrôles au départ à cayenne et puis à
l'arrivée à orly et ce renforcement de
contrôles
il s'est accompagné d'un renforcement
des effectifs voilà pour la première
mesure et qui est en oeuvre dès à
présent s'agissant de la deuxième mesure
nous avons tout au long de l'année 2017
2018 renforcer les effectifs qui sont en
charge de la lutte contre les trafics de
stupéfiants en guyane sur le territoire
guyanais et donc c'est ses agents ce
sont des agents de la gendarmerie
nationale de la police nationale et des
douanes et qui effectue un travail en
profondeur pour lutter contre les
réseaux de trafic de stupéfiants et puis
troisième piste plus globale
c'est ce que nous a demandé de mettre en
oeuvre le président de la république
oeuvre le premier ministre c'est un plan
global de lutte contre les trafics de
stupéfiants qui inclut dans l'action que
nous menons une collaboration un
partenariat avec les pays de provenance
de cette cocaïne pour mener une action
qui soit beaucoup plus efficace voilà
monsieur le sénateur pourrait compter
sur la détermination du miz de
l'intérieur de l'ensemble du
gouvernement pour lutter contre ce fléau
qu'est le trafic de stupéfiants et
notamment en provenance de la guyane
merci merci la parole et votre collègue
nadine grelet certenais pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain vous avez la
parole sur collègue monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
du travail
le 30 décembre dernier pour les fêtes de
fin d'année paraissait un décret
d'application de la loi
joliment intitulé pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel visant
à renforcer le contrôle des chômeurs
avec l'idée que les français les plus en
difficultés les plus fragiles seraient
responsables de leur exclusion
voici donc comment ce décret entend
responsabiliser ceux qui déconne ceux
qui n'ont pas le sens de l'effort selon
les termes choquant employés sans
vergogne par le président de la
république
ainsi dès le premier refus d'une offre
le chercheur d'emploi pourra être radiés
des listes de pôle emploi
l'offre raisonnable d'emploi et
redéfinit le salaire précédent n'est
plus un argument de refus dès le premier
manquement la location est supprimé non
suspendues ce qui permettait auparavant
de conserver ses droits
enfin
la surveillance sera assurée par le
journal de bord numérique qui permettra
de contrôler en temps réel les chômeurs
les syndicats ont bien sûr fortement
réagi contre ce nouveau caporalisme
déshumanisé à l'égard des demandeurs
d'emploi on ne peut vouloir baisser le
chômage en radiant les allocataires ou
en accroissant la précarité des exclus
emplois en raison de la masse des
dossiers suivi l'explosion des cdd de
moins d'un mois
les agents de pôle emploi estime que ce
climat de suspicion dénature leur
mission sans compter le fait que vous
avez supprimer 800 postes dans la
dernière loi de finances ne serait-il
pas temps madame la ministre à l'heure
où vous semblez vouloir adopter une
autre attitude à l'égard des syndicats
et ont vu du grand débat de modifier
votre analyse de la situation d'emploi
de privilégier enfin l'accompagnement
plutôt que la sanction des plus
précaires et questionner non pas
seulement l'employabilité des personnes
mais le nombre et la qualité des emplois
proposés par les entreprises du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice nadine grelet c'est
retenez vous m'interrogez sur le décret
du 30 décembre qui intervient en
application de la loi pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel
promulguée le 5 septembre dernier
alors quel est le sens du contrôle il a
hâte sans ce double le premier c'est que
dans tout système de solidarité
collective il faut un équilibre des
droits et des devoirs
le deuxième sens c'est que on constate
empiriquement et se vient des équipes de
pôle emploi que le contrôle parfois
permet de remobiliser
je vous donne un exemple sur les 300
milles contrôles aléatoires café pôle
emploi dans la dernière vague sursaut
demandeurs d'emploi 66 chercher
activement un emploi 20% étaient
découragés et on peut le comprendre
il baissait après avoir fait des tas et
des tas de démarches il ya un jour on
baisse les bras parce que c'est un peu
désespérant
le fait de dans le contrôle de s'en
apercevoir a permis de remobiliser et le
demandeur d'emploi et les équipes de
pôle emploi avec des très beaux succès
ensuite
et puis 14% ne cherchait pas activement
un emploi et n'avait pas de difficultés
particulières de santé de logement
d'éloignement ou des difficultés qu'on
peut comprendre et qui sont prises en
compte dans le contrôle
alors pour cela oui le contrôle a été
revu pourquoi parce qu'il était
également injuste et inéquitable
jusqu'ici dans le cadre de l'offre de
recherche dans l'offre raisonnable
d'emploi que d'ailleurs les
gouvernements précédents n'ont jamais
supprimé donc vous l'avez soutenu
également il y avait un système injuste
c'est considéré de la même façon une
femme seule qui habite dans une zone
rurale et qui doit contraindre par les
horaires de crèches pour pouvoir placer
son enfant est travaillée qui vont être
sanctionnés parce qu'elle refusait un
emploi mais par contre le cadre dans une
métropole sur un métier où il n'y a pas
de chômage lui avait n'avait pas
forcément de sanctions et donc on a
simplement fait quelque chose de plus
équitable qui vient de l'expérience du
terrain des agents de pôle emploi c'est
que aujourd'hui on ne peut plus être
sanctionnés de façon on ne peut pas être
pénalisé pour une un sujet sur lequel on
n'a pas la prise est concrètement ça
veut dire que dès le premier jour de
demandeurs d'emploi au confluent
conseiller pôle emploi vont définir sur
quelles bases l'emploi peut être
recherchée et contrôlés dans une
certaine madame la ministre vous
poursuivi une logique technocratique
avec ce décret vous ajoutez de la
culpabilité la précarité vous mettez en
danger une population déjà affectés par
le sentiment d'injustice ce décret très
mauvaise augure en vue de la réforme
systémique de l'assurance chômage
actuellement sur la table de négociation
vous parler d' équilibre des droits et
devoirs qu'en est il des fraudeurs
fiscaux par ailleurs la parole est à
notre collègue catherine de roche pour
le groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et porte sur la politique fiscale
depuis plusieurs mois nous avons assisté
à des atermoiements successifs du
gouvernement je ne reviendrai pas sur la
taxe sur les carburants sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés existent l'exit tax les
charges sur les sur les heures
supplémentaires la la csg et bien
d'autres la liste est très longue et
récemment nous avons eu en effet des
déclarations contradictoires sur la taxe
d'habitation sur l'impôt sur les
successions ou sur les sf mardi dernier
le président la république a rajouté
j'allais dire au catalogue les 80 km
heure les réversions donc ma question
est simple pouvez vous éclairer le sénat
ou tenter d'éclairer le sénat sur la
feuille de route en matière de politique
fiscale pour répondre aux exigences
fixées par le président de la république
pour vous répondre l'accord les cobistes
de l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire veut la parole monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je vais vous rassurer sur
notre feuille de route
notre feuille de route c'est baisser les
impôts baisser d impôt pour les ménages
baisser les impôts pour les entreprises
bc impôts pour les ménages la taxe
d'habitation
vous connaissez la conviction sur le
sujet j'estime que cet impôt doit être
totalement supprimée pour l'ensemble des
ménages
ça n'exclut pas que la question soit
posée aux français mais je vous rappelle
la position qui est la mienne
s'agissant de la fiscalité sur le
capital lisf le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique
je vous redis aussi ma conviction forte
il faut baisser l'impôt sur le capital
pour que nos entreprises puissent
investir et innover créer des emplois et
donc je suis favorable à ce que nous
maintenions la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune et le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique mais vous êtes de ce
côté-là de l'hémicycle comme je le pense
dans tout cet hémicycle favorable à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays
il n'y aura pas de reconquête
industrielle en france sans baisser les
impôts et les taxes sur le capital et
sans baisser les impôts de production
sur l'industrie ça fait 20 ans que l'on
fait croire aux français qu'on peut
avoir une industrie forte avec des
impôts élevés et bien le million
d'emplois supprimés dans l'industrie
montrent que ce n'est pas la bonne voie
nous poursuivrons donc la baisse des
impôts sur l'industrie et sur l'ensemble
des entreprises françaises en ramenant
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 33 % à 25 %
en france d'ici 2022
ça n'exclut pas non plus madame des
roches baisser les impôts pour tous les
français baisser les impôts pour
l'économie en france 2 un point minimum
sur cinq ans
cela n'empêche pas non plus d'aller
chercher l'argent là où il se trouve et
de mettre en place comme nous allons le
faire une juste taxe sur les géants du
numérique qui s'appliquera à compter du
1er janvier 2019 pour que tous les gens
du numérique payant france le même
montant d'impôt que nos pme et nos
petites entreprises madame de roche
un jour bien si le monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre vous avez
donnez vos propres convictions mais nous
avons beaucoup de déclarations de vos
collègues du gouvernement qui sont
contraires à ce que vous venez de dire
or on a eu vingt mois d'une politique
péremptoire avec aucun écho à nos
propositions
maintenant nous sommes sûr parti pour
quelques mois d'incertitude jusqu'à la
fin du débat mais que de temps perdu et
que n'avez vous écoutez les sénateurs
nous qui sommes au plus près du terrain
et qui connaissons la vraie vie c'est
pas tango permanent déclaratif sont
terriblement anxiogène pour nos
concitoyens que ce soit les chefs
d'entreprise les agriculteurs les
particuliers les classes enfin les
classes moyennes les familles cela
change tout le temps et chacun voit bien
ce qui est donné d'une main repris
doublement voire plus de l'autre côté
donc je terminerai par une formule d'un
économiste pourtant modérées la
politique fiscale du gouvernement ce
n'est plus une usine à gaz mais toute
une zone industrielle
merci car l'état jean pierre moga pour
un groupe de l'union centriste avait la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues que
sur le ministre j'attire votre attention
sur la création et l'exploitation d'une
retenue d'eau collective le lac de
caussade en lot-et-garonne
il s'agit d'un lac collinaire de moins
de 2 millions de mètres cubes destinés à
l'irrigation
la réalisation de ce lac serait pour les
agriculteurs en espoirs une partie des
eaux de pluies hivernales pourraient
être stockées pour être utilisé en
période estivale
ce serait aussi une opportunité de
maintenir un étiage convenable du petit
ruisseau en aval de la retenue pendant
l'été les porteurs de projets dans le
monde agricole comme d'ailleurs dans
d'autres secteurs se heurte à des textes
qui rentrent de camille quasiment
impossible la réalisation de telles
opérations
c'est peut-être cette complexité des
lois et des normes qui a poussé les
agriculteurs en fendre la loi et
entreprend dans la construction de
l'ouvragé solution que je déplore mais
qui est une règle une réalité
dans ce contexte nous risquons de vivre
un nouveau 6 vs
merci weis ou à la place des artistes il
y aurait des agriculteurs maintenir la
paix sociale avec le monde agricole
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard est une
priorité absolue monsieur le ministre
les agriculteurs sont déjà respectable
qui doivent irriguer leurs cultures pour
nourrir la population
aujourd'hui ils doivent faire face à
d'importantes mutations comme jamais ils
sont à bout je vous demande donc quelle
mesure vous envisagez de prendre afin de
résoudre ce problème et d'en sortir par
le haut enfin vous le savez comme moi
le changement climatique est
malheureusement en marche le monde de
rural va vivre des périodes de
sécheresses de plus en plus importante
aussi envisagez vous d'adapter la loi
sur l'eau afin de mieux répondre aux
défis majeurs majeur qui nous attendent
merci françois de rugy milices d'état
merci évident mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur moga vous
avez raison la question de l'accès à
l'eau est un des enjeux clés les effets
du dérèglement climatique
particulièrement dans la grande région
sud ouest où on constate déjà
aujourd'hui tous les ans de graves
déficits en eau et c'est pour cela que
c'est la priorité que nous avons fixés à
la deuxième phase des assises de l'eau
donc tous les acteurs élus locaux mais
aussi représentants des agriculteurs des
industriels des consommateurs qui
réfléchit sur la réforme de notre
politique de l'eau c'est bien
l'adaptation dérèglement climatique et
notamment la question du stockage de
l'eau car il faut bien appeler les
choses par leur nom s'agissant de la
situation à caussade
je tiens à rappeler que ce projet n'a
jamais pu apporter la preuve de sa
compatibilité avec le schéma
d'aménagement et de gestion de l'eau le
fameux sage que tous les élus locaux
connaissent bien et le respect des
directives européennes
vigueur et cela malgré plusieurs alertes
et c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé avec le
ministre de l'agriculture à l'époque
donc stéphane travert le retrait de
l'arrêté préfectoral de juin 2018 qui
avait été pris contre l'avis de deux
préfets de région et nous en avons
d'ailleurs tiré les conséquences
concernant la préfecture de département
malgré cela le projet a été lancé il
légalement par le porteur de projet et
vous l'avez dit un peu en quelque sorte
en situation inversée de sivens qui est
malheureusement de triste mémoire j'ai
donc donné immédiatement des
instructions pour que l'ensemble des
démarches soit engagée et notamment par
la justice pour constater l'illégalité
des travaux ce qui a été fait il existe
d'ailleurs des systèmes d'astreintes
financières pour non respect des
décisions de justice et qui vont être
enclenchée par l'état mais cet exemple
négatif ne doit pas nous détourner de
l'objectif que nous partageons avec
didier guillot ministre de l'agriculture
de trouver des solutions concrètes pour
le stockage de l'eau la gestion de la
ressource en eau avec des fortes pluies
parfois à certains moments et des
périodes de sécheresse il y à l'exemple
des deux sèvres qui peut nous être très
instructif et nous allons donc agir dans
ce sens lui même si la parole est
maintenant notre collègue julien
bargeton pour le groupe de la république
embarque la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues la liberté de la presse
à côté du suffrage universel c'est la
pensée de tous à côté du gouvernement de
tous a tenté à l'une c'est attenter à
l'autre ainsi s'exprime et victor hugo
l'un de nos éminents collègues s'étaient
dits fiscaux main est aujourd'hui trop
souvent attaqué les agressions répétées
de journalistes sont inadmissibles et
met en danger le pacte républicain en
s'attaquant à la presse en bloquant la
diffusion de journaux en menaçant une
journaliste de viol comme à toulouse en
insultant en permanence sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est la république qu on
agresse mais personne ne tordra le bras
à la république
la france n'acceptera jamais de
banaliser le bâillon ailleurs la liberté
de la presse c'est peut-être un luxe
c'est peut-être une chute une chimère en
france c'est un droit fondamental
informé créer le débat
divertir et je n'oublie pas que dans le
monde des journalistes ont payé de leurs
prix cette liberté et je n'oublie pas
les victimes de l'attentât du 7 janvier
charlie hebdo qui ont prié de leurs prix
de leur vie cette liberté fondamentale
alors comme les français gardent en
mémoire ce souvenir il la meilleure
façon d'honorer nos morts de les
respecter c'est de défendre sur le
terrain comme en ligne la liberté de la
presse et le travail des journalistes
monsieur le ministre à l'heure où là
toute la france s'apprête à débattre
quelles sont les mesures que le
gouvernement prend pour défendre cette
liberté et sanctionner ceux qui
souhaiteraient y attentes et je vous
remercie
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
mobilise par le charge d'assurer que
parlement merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bert jetons merci
de votre question dans ses fondements
et puis aussi dans l'occasion que nous
offre de pouvoir répondre aux questions
que vous posez la déclaration des droits
de l'homme de 1789 indique que la libre
communication des pensées et des
opinions est un des droits de l'homme
les plus précieux de l'homme
sans cette liberté sans les médias sans
les journalistes et leur travail il n'y
a pas de démocratie possible des
journalistes en sont les vigies une
démocratie qui ne défend pas sa presse
et une démocratie qui s'oublie ligne
demain est une démocratie qui se nuit le
journaliste peut évidemment être
contestées critiquer doit bien sûr faire
l'objet de controverses
il doit aussi rendre des comptes mais
rien ne justifie les appels à la
défiance puis à la haine puis à la
violence que nous avons entendues et
rien ne justifiera que l'on cherche par
la force ou par la peur à bâillonner les
uns ou les autres dans ce débat qui nous
occupe où les journalistes sont de plus
en plus souvent mise en cause dans le
débat public
il est une arme essentielle c'est
l'éducation aux médias
et nous ne ménageons pas des efforts sur
ce sujet le traitement de l'information
appelle aussi les exigences
déontologiques la plus forte c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement a confié une
mission à emmanuel hogg
comme vous le savez qu'ils procèdent
depuis quelques semaines à une
concertation la plus large possible sur
le sujet pour aboutir à des propositions
défendre la liberté de la presse est
aussi lutter contre les tentatives de
manipulation de l'information qui
sévissent et que nous avons vu encore à
l'oeuvre c'est la vision qui préside à
la loi promulguée le 25 décembre dernier
c'est aussi soutenir le modèle
économique de la presse et c'est ce que
nous faisons au niveau européen et c'est
ce que le travail qui est fait aussi
dans les deux assemblées sur ce question
c'est défend la défendent la liberté la
presse et aussi rendre possible la
diffusion des idées sur le tout le
territoire et c'est pour cela que nous
prenons à bras le corps la question de
la distribution de la presse en droite
soutenant le redressement de presstalis
défend les libertés la démocratie tu es
aussi défendre les permettrait de le
dire les parlementaires menacer les élus
locaux menacer les citoyens privés leurs
exercices de circulation leurs exercices
leur libre exercice de circulation ou de
droit simplement à exercer une activité
c'est défendre les institutions menacés
ou les ministères envahissent et défend
les parlementaires je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure et donc nous cette question
démocratique elle touche la fois la
presse vous voyez les éléments qu'on a
sur la table et il touche l'ensemble des
institutions et je crois que c'est un
sentiment que nous partageons les uns
les autres jours merci georges e tour
dont la parole est à notre collègue
muriel jourda pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre à
ma question s'adresse à vous je crois en
bicamérisme qui garantit une démocratie
mieux équilibrée il n'est pas de
république forte sans institutions
puissantes nez de temps troublés nos
institutions sont résistantes aux crises
et aux turbulences johar que sur
d'autres connu monsieur le premier
ministre le discours d' emmanuel macron
président de la république
aucune grey lors des mois de juillet
2017 et 2018 et il avait raison
nous connaissons une crise sociale une
crise culturelle une crise territoriales
mais nous ne connaissons pas de crise
des institutions pour autant dans sa
lettre aux français le président de la
république met en discussion la
transformation du sénat quelles sont vos
intentions à l'égard du sénat la parole
monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous avez cité le président de la
république dans son discours voudrais
vous auriez pu aussi même si c'est moins
prestigieux site et le premier ministre
à l'occasion du discours que j'ai
prononcé pour la première fois au sénat
je reconnais que ça a moins de pastis
mais mais vous mais vous reconnaîtrez
aussi madame la sénatrice que à
l'occasion de ce discours j'avais
indiqués mon attachement bicamérisme le
rôle essentiel dans une démocratie de ce
dialogue permanent entre deux assemblées
qui tirent leur légitimité
deux modes de désignation différentes
temporalités différentes
c' est un élément constitutif
constitutif de notre équilibre
démocratique et j'observe que ce n'est
pas propre au génie français même s'il
est considérable puisque dans toutes les
démocraties c'est ce dialogue qui permet
une forme de sagesse et d' équilibre
donc je n'ai aucun problème madame la
sénatrice à dire aujourd'hui comme je
les ai toujours dit que j'étais attaché
et au bicamérisme et au sénat et
j'observe que et j'observe madame la
sénatrice que dire ceci ne doit pas je
pense que vous pourrez le reconnaître
avec moi nous exonérer d'une réflexion
sur le bon fonctionnement du bicamérisme
sur la bonne désignation de ceux qui
siègent dans ces deux instances sûr mais
enfin bien entendu vous avez cité le
mouvement des gilet jaune reconnaissait
avec moi que dans la très grande masse
de revendications qui sont exprimés dans
leur très grande diversité
il y a aussi des questionnements pas
forcément sur l'existence de telles ou
telles assemblées mais sur la capacité
de telle ou telle assemblée a
correctement représenté la population
française je ne dis pas madame la
sénatrice
je ne dis pas madame la sénatrice que
c'est les seules revendications mais
nous pouvons je crois reconnaître que
ces questions sont posées âme dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre
le président de la république dans le
débat qu'il a engagées a ouvert un
chapitre sur la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
posons des questions dans la démocratie
et la citoyenneté sur la participation
de nos concitoyens la prise de décision
que ce soit d'ailleurs au niveau local
ou au niveau national sur la
représentation de nos concitoyens sur le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
sur ce besoin de participation de nos
concitoyens il a souhaité faire en sorte
que le débat soit ouvert
le président du sénat a choisi à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
qui se tenait dé je croise ce matin
monsieur le président d'indiquer c'est
lui appartenait l'attachement rappelé
par le président de la république au
bicamérisme il n'y a pas de sujet là
dessus en revanche je serai toujours
ouverts à cette discussion qui est une
discussion qui doit être continu dans le
temps pour faire en sorte que nos
institutions fonctionnent mieux que
notre bicamérisme fonctionne mieux que
nos citoyens soient toujours convaincu
qu'il fonctionne comme il devrait
fonctionner c'est ça le sens du débat et
je crois que ce sont des questions très
raisonnable et qui intéressent nos
concitoyens
voilà le genre d'or j'entends votre
réponse monsieur le premier ministre
nous sommes d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faille mener une réflexion je rappelle
d'ailleurs qu'elle avait commencé dans
les assemblées avant de se dérouler sur
les ronds-points et qu'à aucun moment le
sénat ne s'était montré hostile à cette
réflexion
mais puisque nous sommes en temps de
grands débats je vais pouvoir faire
aussi
si vous permettez quelques observations
d'abord pour rappeler qu'avant tout le
président de la république au terme de
notre constitution
il est garant garante des institutions
et sans doute devra-t-il résister à la
tentation de jeter ses institutions en
pâture au mécontentement de la
population pour précisément faire
changer d'objets à ce mécontentement
je rajouterai aussi que le président de
la république semble finalement beaucoup
s'inspirer du sénat désormais ces temps
derniers
j'en prendrai quelques exemples
lorsqu'il évoque le travail sur le
statut de l'élu lors de sa réunion
devant les maires de l'heure il parle du
rapport de nos collègues bocal dardoup
lorsqu'il évoque l'évolution de la loi
notre le président la république parle
de la proposition de loi pas retailleau
d'arnaud lorsqu'il évoque l'adaptation
locale de la limitation de vitesse à 80
km/heure il parle du rapport de nos
collègues raison du lien fichet
lorsqu'il évoque les objectifs annuels
en matière d'immigration dans sa lettre
aux français
le président de la république parle de
l'amendement récent de notre collègue
roger karoutchi
lorsqu'il veut prendre des mesures
contre les casseurs conclure le
président des règlements longue reprend
la proposition de loi du président
retailleau avant de songer à transformer
le sénat peut-être l'exécutif pointu
songer à transformer son regard sur le
sénat nous ne sommes pas qu un
contre-pouvoir encombrants nous sommes
aussi et avant tout la voix des
territoires de france
merci la parole est à notre collègue
brigitte micouleau dont le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre
depuis maintenant deux mois en marge des
manifestations des gilet jaune un
certain nombre de centres villes de
notre pays sont chaque samedi le théâtre
de violences et d'affrontements
inacceptable
on ne compte plus les commerçants
artisans professions libérales qui ont
vu leurs locaux attaquent et dégradés ou
pillées quant à ceux qui ont la chance
d'échapper à ce déchaînement gratuit de
haine
ils vivent dans l'angoissé c'est médias
venir et concepts de semaine en semaine
la mort dans l'âme le déclin de leurs
activités craignant pour leur sécurité
les clients délaissent un effet
massivement les centres-villes chiffre
d'affaires en baisse de plus de 40%
chômage technique licenciement constitue
aujourd'hui le lot quotidien de nos
commerçants artisans restaurateurs
hôteliers l'avenir si rien ne change si
rien n'est fait pour les soutenir
une très probable explosion du nombre de
dépôts de bilan
or monsieur le ministre ces commerçants
et ses artisans jouent un rôle
économique mais aussi sociale plusieurs
municipalités consciente qu'il ne peut
exister de centre ville sans commerces
vont prendre des mesures d'urgence c'est
le cas de toulouse où un conseil
municipal exceptionnel examinera un plan
de dead de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros
mais les communes ne peuvent pas tous
les maires prennent leur responsabilité
l'état doit également prendre les
siennes
plusieurs propositions d'aidé
individualisée seront demandés notamment
l'exonération non le saint et non le
simple report des charges sociales
patronales pour les mois de décembre et
de janvier de l'acf ainsi que le report
de la mise en application de la révision
des valeurs locatives commercial
monsieur le ministre
entendez-vous désespoir des commerçants
et artisans des centres villes
comptez-vous leur venir en aide secure
gens pour vous répondre la parole est
aux ministres de l'économie et des
finances dessus bruno le maire et madame
la sénatrice micouleau je partage
totalement ce que vous venez de dire
j'ai eu l'occasion il ya plus d'un mois
de dire que ces violences ces
dégradations de commerces magasins
ces pillages était inacceptable et
qu'ils avaient un impact catastrophique
sur notre économie
je maintiens ces termes la violence les
dégradations les pillages les menaces
contre des commerçants sont
inacceptables et ont un impact
catastrophique sur notre économie est
toujours sur les plus petits commerces
surtout ceux qui ont des commerces de
centre ville qui ne peuvent plus exercer
librement leurs activités
c'est un impact également sur les
grandes surfaces qui ont du mal à
s'approvisionner
ç'a eu un impact considérable sur la
restauration sur l'hôtellerie dans une
période de fêtes qui est normalement une
période le chiffre d'affaires est élevé
cela n'impacte très important dans des
secteurs très spécifiques
le jouet l'alimentation l'habillement
nous allons faire le bilan des soldes
d'ici quelques jours pour voir l'impact
concret que ce live
je vous confirme que nous avons mis en
place la cellule d'urgence au ministère
de l'économie et des finances nous y
travaillons avec noyal pénicaud la
ministre du travail pour que nous
puissions avoir cet allègement de
charges pour ceux qui ont été le plus
touché nous restons en permanence ouvert
au dialogue avec les représentants des
commerçants et des artisans
je vous confirme également que nous
avons sollicité les assureurs pour
qu'ils répondent le plus rapidement
possible aux difficultés de ses
commerçants et puis nous sommes en train
de faire un bilan précis de l'évaluation
de l'impact économique du mouvement en
cours et des violences auxquelles elles
ont donné lieu pour que nous puissions
mesurer précisément l'impact de ce
mouvement sur la croissance française et
sur notre économie
en tout cas ma porte comme celle de
mener les pénicaud reste ouverte en
permanence aux parlementaires qui le
souhaitent aux représentants des
commerçants des artisans de toutes les
activités économiques pour que nous
travaillons ensemble aux solutions
les plus efficaces possibles merci
j'aurais salué dans cet hémicycle
madame françoise ramon notre nouvelle
collègue sénatrice de la loire depuis le
2 janvier
[Applaudissements]
prochaine question d'actualité le mardi
22 janvier
je vais suspendre la séance et sera
reprise à 16h15 pour le débat sur le
retrait britannique de l'union
européenne en vieux français breake site
la science est suspendu pour dix minutes
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement qui a été
marquée par le grand débat national et
notamment par la réforme des
institutions la sénatrice les
républicains muriel jourda a interrogé
le gouvernement sur la remise en
question du rôle du sénat notamment dans
la lettre aux français d'emmanuel macro
edouard philippe
le premier ministre lui a répondu en
disant qu'il était toujours très attaché
au big améris mme dans les institutions
mais il a affirmé qu' il pouvait être
bond d'engager une réflexion sur la
bonne désignation des membres du
parlement et sur la participation des
citoyens à la fabrication de la loi
globalement dans ce grand débat national
les sénateurs souhaitent que qu'il y ait
une nouvelle étape dans la
décentralisation et que ce grand débat
se conclut par une grande conférence
sociale et territoriale pour redonner la
parole aux partenaires sociaux et aux
élus locaux
edouard philippe le premier ministre a
indiqué qu'il était plutôt favorable que
c'était une bonne proposition mais qu'il
souhaitait que les élus locaux
participent d'abord à cette grande
consultation
et puis autre moment fort dans cette
séance la question de la sénatrice
communiste
esther benbassa sur les violences
policières pendant les manifestations
gilet jaune elle a parlé de gazage de
respect de répression disproportionnée
sous les huées de la droite sénatoriale
le secrétaire d'état alors en une aise
secrétaire d'état au ministère de
l'intérieur à lui défendu les policiers
et l'usagé je cite cadre et du flash
ball qui est fait face à des
manifestants qui je cite cherche parfois
à lyncher et à tuer les policiers
voilà pour les temps forts de cette
séance de questions d'actualité merci
beaucoup alexandre pour vos explications
on va continuer à d'analyser les temps
forts de cet ac ans avec mon invité
aujourd'hui elles nadia salut bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation de
puis mixez la sénatrice centriste de la
nièvre on va parler évidemment de ce
grand débat mais aussi de l'avenir du
sénat et
du saison peut-être puisque gérard
larcher l'a rappelé ce matin n'y aura
pas de fusion pourtant et ça l'a fait
toujours partie et bien des
interrogations sur cette réforme
institutionnelle on va y venir un à dire
se loupe dans un ensemble si vous voulez
bien on retourne salle des conférences
puisque la ministre des affaires
européennes nathalie l'oiseau est au
micro de talent fera nuit et oui
nathalie l'oiseau nous allons parler
ensemble de ce break site le break si
dur est il pour vous aujourd'hui
inévitable nous sommes et bien à la
veille à quelques minutes de ce débat
qui va avoir lieu au sénat sur ce sujet
nous sommes dans une période
d'incertitude
les européens ont négocié et conclu avec
le gouvernement britannique un accord de
retrait qui permet une séparation
raisonnable sens et ordonnée entre
l'europe et le royaume uni cet accord de
retrait la première mise rita nick l'a
soumis à la ratification de la chambre
des communes
et elle a essuyé un échec est ce que ça
veut dire que cet accord de retrait est
totalement mort nous ne le pensons pas
aujourd'hui a pas 36 solutions il y en a
trois soit on veut un accord de retrait
on veut un retrait ordonné et c'est cet
accord qui a été négocié qui ne compte
pas réouvrir soit on est prêt à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de briques site ça c'est aux
britanniques de le dire et nous la porte
reste ouverte fameux remake soit il
c'est un retrait brutal sans accord et
c'est de moins en moins improbable
c'est la raison pour laquelle a les mots
du premier ministre aujourd'hui
absolument c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous préparons un doux euphémisme
peut-être ça vous avez l'impression que
c'est de plus en plus probable écoutez
c'est aux britanniques de se déterminer
mais en tout cas c'est à nous
responsables politiques d'être prêt pour
tous les scénarios notamment en cas
d'absence d'accord nous voulons défendre
les intérêts des citoyens français des
britanniques qui réside sur notre sol
parce qu'ils sont les bienvenus les
intérêts de nos entreprises c'est ce que
nous faisons avec ce projet de loi qui
je l'espère sera adoptée tout à l'heure
qui permettra d' option définitive qui
habilite le gouvernement à légiférer par
ordonnances exactement et à cinq
ordonnances qui sont en cours de
préparation elles sont même prêtes pour
dire les choses
la première sera présenté au conseil des
ministres dès la semaine prochaine si
projet doit être adopté
donc nous allons vite nous serons prêts
nous avons mis des moyens de côtes et
des moyens humains des moyens financiers
pour faire en sorte que
on puisse continuer à circuler de part
et d'autre de la manche et que de notre
côté
la fluidité du trafic sera assuré oui
effectivement parce que le break ce
titre les breaks si durs sont des
problèmes très concrets des problèmes
pour les douanes des problèmes pour les
ports des problèmes pour les aéroports
pour l'industrie aéronautique aussi
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques uns des exemples de ces
problèmes que cela peut poser alors s'il
n'y a pas d'accord ça cela suppose que
nous rétablissions des contrôles
douaniers des contrôles réglementaires
pour les personnes et pour les
marchandises qui arrivent du royaume uni
pour cela il faut donc davantage de
policiers davantage de douaniers
davantage de vétérinaire et ils sont
recrutés ils sont en train d'être formés
ce que vous nous voulons c'est que
laisser contrôler aille vite pour ne pas
embouteiller la circulation donc il faut
des aires de stationnement là dessus des
autorisations sont demandés des
infrastructures temporaires seront
construites pour être prêt au 30 mars
bien merci beaucoup nathalie l'oiseau
d'avoir répondu à mes questions alors
qu'effectivement je vous le disais il va
y avoir un débat qui va se tenir sur ce
sujet au sénat d'ici une dizaine de
minutes
merci à vous et âme pour cette réaction
directe nadia seul bogey sur notre
plateau sénatrice centriste de la nièvre
ya de réelles menaces qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur le sénat le fait que ça
soit évoqué le rôle de cette institution
dans le grand débat on a appris et bien
que cette question était sur la table
dans la lettre d' emmanuel macron oui
alors évidemment c'est une inquiétude en
ce qui concerne la représentation le
fonctionnement de la démocratie en
france
j'ai du mal moi même à imaginer que
convie se remettre en cause le
bicamérisme mais probablement que le
sénat a un rôle qui est mal compris et
peut-être de ces gens qui sont arrivés
au bout de leur colère et qui finalement
trouvé une façon ultime de manifester en
essayant de bloquer la france pour se
faire entendre
d'après ce que j'entends le sénat est
très mal compris et les gens ne
retiennent qu'une chose c'est que les
sénateurs ce sont des gens qui ont
d'énormes facilité et qui finalement
n'ont pas une grande utilité
alors je me dis que peut-être en termes
de communication c'est vrai qu'ils sont
peut-être abreuver bien sûr je parle pas
public sénat mais ils sont abreuvés de
reportages ou ans lors des bals des
scandales qui moi même
mes pattes parce que je ne vois même pas
comment on peut arriver à nantes se
parler mon tarif c'est ce que vous dites
voilà c'est ça et par content de m'être
questions institutionnelles
elle doit être écarté du grand débat
alors il faut que les gens puissent
s'exprimer dans le grand débat par
contre il ya quelque chose qui enfin le
grand débat lui-même n'arrive que parce
qu'il ya un problème avec les
institutions parce que théoriquement les
gens devraient pas avoir besoin d'être
sur un rond point d'avoir un gilet jaune
il devrait pouvoir s'adresser à leurs
députés et être entendu enfin je parle
de monsieur tout le monde allait voir
son député que leur et députés puissent
librement et en dehors de toute
considération poligrip par les avocats
direct parce qu'ils ont le sentiment que
la démocratie représentative ne
fonctionne pas bien que c'est exactement
ça voilà si ça fonctionnait normalement
qu'ils avaient l'impression est que ça
remonte vraiment ils n'auraient pas
besoin d'avoir un ami un grand débat ni
des excès de cette nature après
concernant le sénat c'est vrai qu'il
serait vraiment intéressant que le grand
public est également des reportages sur
ce qu'on fait de bien au sénat à savoir
faire remonter la voix des territoires
et de nos collègues maires ou vraiment
introduire les amendements concret la
pédagogie autour du travail
parlementaire s'est même retournée salle
des conférences
puisque tu es en train de nuit et vous
êtes avec bruno retailleau lancé le
président du groupe plr ici au sénat oui
bruno retailleau et bien tout d'abord
une question est bien sûr le bicamérisme
c'était un sujet sur lequel est
intervenu
gérard larcher ce matin il faut dire que
eh bien il a été passablement agacé par
la lettre aux français qui a été adressé
par emmanuel macron et qui parlait d'une
transformation du sénat voire une
suppression on peut l'imaginer qui
ouvrait le débat là dessus a bien sûr
peut-être que monsieur macron veut
encore plus de pouvoir peut-être qu'il
voudrait qu'il y ait aucun
contre-pouvoir en face de lui
on voit bien d'ailleurs sur la question
de monsieur benalla mais on le voit sur
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres questions
d'ailleurs le gouvernement souvent vient
désormais de piocher des bonnes idées
dont il a besoin par exemple sur contre
les violences et et est beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres idées aussi de notre
proposition n'a pas dit anticasseurs
voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
démocratie c'est pas seulement suffrage
universel c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs et c'est le sénat qui porte
cette séparation des pouvoirs c'est le
sénat qui porte aussi une voie
différente la voix des territoires et
monsieur mac on ne peut pas dire j'ai
besoin des mères j'ai besoin des
territoires jeu
vous écoutez et en même temps vouloir
plus ou moins rabaisser le sénat qui est
l'ambassadeur et la voix des territoires
voix des territoires faut-il revenir
pour vous sur le non cumul c'est
important face à une certaine
déconnexion des élus on entend et bien
cette musique qui est en train de monter
et puis même emmanuel macron qui a dit
ne pas y être opposé pour les très
petites communes
bien sûr qu' il faut des élus qui sont
enracinés et là encore il ya un paradoxe
mais schéma qu'on adore les paradoxes
il voudrait encore plus de
proportionnelle la proportionnelle c'est
quoi ces données la main aux partis
politiques de faire élire de faire élire
des gens qui sont des apparatchiks
voilà qui ne sont pas du tout implanté
dans le territoire mais parce que ils
ont été désignés par leur parti
politique est bien mise en place dans
des listes très très haut dans des
listes ils se feront élire grâce si
j'ose dire à ces investitures là c'est
la négation du lien entre l'homme le
peuple et puis en même temps le
territoire va avoir une espèce une
expérience locale et ensuite devenir
parlementaire et ne plus avoir un
exécuté mais aujourd'hui mais vous
verrez on l'a bien vu sur la fin sur
cette crise
cette crise et territoires cette
déconnexion et on le voit avec un
certain nombre de lits aujourd'hui la
force du sénat par exemple c'est que
pour la plupart nous sommes des élus
ancré dans les territoires nous avons
été maire président département
président de région et c'est ça qui est
important mais qu'est ce que veulent les
français ils veulent que les élus les
écouter comporter préoccupations du
terrain jusqu'à paris une fois qu'on
sera devenu des élus par seul
croyez moi la crise de la démocratie
elle s'aggravera la commission denquête
benalla votre réaction à la garde à vue
d'alexandre benalla dans le volet des
passeports diplomatiques certains ne
sont guère étonnés après les révélations
qu'il y avait hier du directeur de
cabinet patrick strzoda
voilà une belle illustration de la
nécessité du bicamérisme c'est à dire
d'avoir bien sûr l'assemblée nationale
et puis une autre assemblée qui
s'appelle le sénat parce que l'assemblée
nationale disait non non non non il n'y
a rien à faire il ya rien à voir mais si
la justice s'intéresse au cas de
monsieur bénard c'est bien que tout ça
n'était pas anodin donc nous avons eu
raison de persister d'essayer de
connaître les dysfonctionnements au plus
haut niveau de l'état
donc cette affaire banale à elle
justifie le bicamérisme la présence du
sénat parce qu'on voit bien que lorsque
les institutions sont d'un seul côté
lorsque
si demain on avait des institutions avec
tous les pleins pouvoirs au président de
république dans les mains d'un seul
homme et bien à ce moment là nos
institutions fonctionnent mal et je
pense que tous ceux qui sont attachés à
la démocratie sont aussi attachés à cet
équilibre des pouvoirs une toute
dernière question d'actualité c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des sujets qui a ouvert
la séance tout à l'heure la question des
violences policières
le défenseur des droits demande la
suspension des lanceurs de balles de
défense
de nombreux manifestants ont été blessés
est ce que vous êtes
de son avis moi je veux rappeler qu'il y
à des policiers qui ont failli être
gâchée je veux rappeler et je me
souviens très bien les images en plein
d'attentes à islamique
je me souviens ces images où les
français embrassait les policiers qui
nous protège donc voilà je pense que la
violence elle était du côté d'un certain
nombre de délinquants de casseurs qui
est assez redondant quête dans une
démocratie
tout doit être sur la table mais je fais
confiance d'abord aux forces de l'ordre
et attention un jour viendra où quand
ils ne pourront plus du tout agir pour
se protéger mais si surtout pour
protéger la république en ce jour
viendra qu'ils déposeront leurs casques
qu'ils déposeront leurs boucliers qui
protégera les institutions qui protégera
la république donc plutôt que de lancer
la pierre si j'ose dire aux forces de
l'ordre qui est des enquêtes très bien
elles se poursuivent l'igpn etc
faisons attention à ne pas d'être hacké
là encore nos institutions et à ne pas
dévaluer ceux qui ont pour mission de
protéger les français de protéger la
république française il ya merci
beaucoup bruno retailleau pour votre
réaction
merci à vous faire agir les propos sur
cet aspect des collections c'est ce
qu'on reproche aussi des parlementaires
etc le terrain alors oui justement je
n'adhère absolument à ce que vient de
dire monsieur retailleau ont ce qui
concerne les élections c'est vrai que la
proportionnelle moi je ne suis pas
faveur je suis pas favorable parce qu'il
faut pas qu'on soit tous des
apparatchiks en effet de la politique
mais par contre je pense que pour
simplifier il faut vraiment imaginer
qu'au sénat nous sommes une assemblée de
mer moi juste il ya 18 mois j'étais
maire d'une commune de 1500 habitants
voilà c'est tout et après je suis passé
directement sénat pour partie porté
cette voie là justement juste d'un élu
de terrain et peut-être qu'on voit les
choses autrement et c'est pour ça que
j'ai dû
à faire la connexion quand je vois le
président de la république qui passent
sept heures avec des élus de terrain
justement ça vaille pu être moi hier à
dire je vous écoute je vous parle je
vous entends et je suis là même au sénat
alors c'est une très bonne nouvelle s'il
accepte de reparler au maire de
rediscuter d' entamer un nouveau
dialogue parce que du coup il va refaire
pareil avec les sénateurs parce que nous
sommes les mêmes nous sommes les mêmes
personnes ce débat dont vous parlez ça a
permis au chef de l'état de lancer le
grand débat national on sait que il mise
beaucoup sur les élus locaux je propose
heures d'écouté et voir un film qui a
été interpellé sur cette question
c'était il ya quelques instants c'est en
ses côtés un certain nombre de questions
ont été posées beaucoup 35 ou 36 je
crois de directement par le président de
la république dans sa lettre qu'il a
adressée aux français en répondant à ces
questions en s'exprimant sur ces sujets
les français vont nous donner un certain
nombre d'indications
il appartiendra ensuite au gouvernement
au parlement à l'ensemble de ceux qui
concourent au débat public d'en faire
leur miel de s'en inspirer dans la
réponse aux questions profondes et
anciennes qui taraude notre société
c'est dans cet esprit que nous nous
engageons et vous évoquez la question la
proposition qui a été formulée par
certaines organisations syndicales pas
toutes mais certaines qui a été
d'ailleurs reprise par certaines
associations d'élus d'organiser au terme
de l'exercice une grande conférence
territoriale et sociale qui permettrait
à l'ensemble des acteurs en question
d'échanger sur ce qui ressort du grand
débat et de le transformer le cas
échéant en propositions de solutions
c'est une bonne proposition
ce que veut ce que le gouvernement
compte faire de cette grande
consultation de ce grand débat c'est ce
qui est le plus important selon vous
certains ont dit
bien que ne voyait pas la finalité de
cette grande consultation
moi j'ai très peur que la finalité c'est
ça va être une gigantesque frustration
parce que les gens sont tellement dans
la sincérité il faut se mettre à la
place des gens qui prennent toute une
soirée pour écrire une longue lettre
avec des détails avec des choses
précises mais qui peut traiter ça de
façon individuelle et personnalisée je
vois vraiment pas du tout alors si tout
ça tombe dans un espèce de magma et que
ces traités de façon globale c'est bien
ça va être extrêmement frustrant pour
les gens je vois pas du tout la sortie
autant j'ai trouvé admirable la réaction
des maires en période de tension un
moment donné on savait pas comment s'en
sortir l samedi presque spontanément ils
ont dit venez dans vos mairies on ouvre
la porte vous avez un endroit où aller
venez on va parler ça c'était formidable
marc manar décidé de formaliser sa en
faisant croire aux gens qu'on va
individuellement prendre en compte leurs
propositions leurs doléances
enfin je trouve que c'est mensonger et
voilà on va continuer à cet entretien a
doublement retourne une dernière fois sa
les conférences avec vous autres amis
puisque vous êtes avec le sénateur la
république en revanche de paris et
julien bargeton il a interpellé le
gouvernement sur la question aussi des
violences à l'encontre des journalistes
oui eh bien tout d'abord julien bargeton
je vais vous interrogez sûr il ya le
grand débat il avait mal commencé la
semaine dernière avec notamment bien le
départ de chantal jouanno il est un
petit peu mieux continuer pour vous avec
notamment et bien la prestation en
parler de cette façon là d' emmanuel
macron devant les maires dans leurs
mêmes macron à montrer finalement qu'il
était à l'écouté des territoires les
maires se sont les ambassadeurs de la
république
il les a écoutés il les a respectés il
leur a répondu longuement et on a vu les
qualités dont il sait faire preuve donc
effectivement il a engagé le débat de
bonne façon et on voit que la plateforme
a ouverte il y a déjà plusieurs
centaines de réunions prévues en
quelques jours donc déjà plusieurs
centaines de réunions qui sont prévues
c'est un moment inédit dans notre
histoire est unique par rapport au monde
aucun autre pays en europe et en france
ne se livre à cet exercice démocratique
moi j'appelle tout le monde à participer
je suis déçu de voir certaines
oppositions pas tout un
ils refusent d'y participer au jeu plus
en plus les oppositions qui accèdent
parce que je sens que je viens comme un
mouvement
je me réjouis je me réjouis d'un
retournement de certaines oppositions à
part la france est soumise mais qui se
disent que finalement mais à ce débat il
est utile il va être pertinent et il va
apporter des choses pour faire bouger la
france et c'est ce que nous attendons
tous je crois vraiment qu'il faut
souligner ce caractère risqué puisque
quand vous posez des questions et bien
vous prenez des risques mais vraiment
inédit dans notre histoire et j'en
attends des fruits oui effectivement
vous l'avez dit inédit est risqué et
comporte encore de nombreux floues
notamment comment est ce qu'on va faire
et bien la synthèse de tout ce qui va
sortir de ce grand débat est également à
mes racines question des garants qui
demeure on ne connaît pas encore tous la
question des de la synthèse est
importante et c'est pourquoi il fallait
mettre des thèmes ça parfois été
critiqué de mettre 4 4 thèmes mais qui
sont très larges
donc ils permettent d'ouvrir les débats
et puis 35 questions posées par le
président de la république mais qui sont
là aussi assez large assez ouverte pour
permettre un débat très vaste et cela
facilitera aussi ce travail de synthèse
et de remonter parce qu'il ya quand même
un cadre certes souple parce que la
fiscalité le pouvoir d'achat on voit
bien que ça peut permettre de parler
tout mais qui permettront quand même de
classer les réponses et ensuite de les
traiter
moi je veux être confiant ne ne
concluons pas le débat avant même qu'il
ne se déroule via merci beaucoup julien
bargeton pour votre mission merci à vous
et à vous lancer quand même un appel aux
français à participer à se saisir de
cette opportunité c'est quand même une
consultation inédite même si elle est
risquée que lance le chef de l'état
alors très bien d'accord on y croit par
contre moi j'ai du mal à comprendre
parce qu'on dit aux gens maintenant on
va vous écoutez exprimez vous et
paradoxalement et parallèlement moi je
suis dans un département qui en déprises
démographique
donc on sait très bien que la réforme
constitutionnelle qui s'annonce va nous
faire perdre de la représentation
parlementaire actuellement nous sommes
deux députés de sénateurs dont quatre
parlementaires dans la nièvre
le projet c'est de passer à deux donc
nous on perd pas 30% de représentation
parlementaire on perd 50% de
représentation parlementaire donc
comment on peut dire dans le même temps
aux gens on va vous écouter encore plus
venez vous écrire nous écrire on est là
pour vous mais à partir de
demain matin vous serez deux fois moins
représentés mais ce sera mieux comme ça
voilà quand même quelque chose que j'ai
du mal à comprendre
merci à vous et à gaza merci d'être venu
sur le plateau de public sénat on voit
retourner salle des conférences pour
écouter jean pierre sueur sénateur
socialiste du loiret il était au micro
le talf rallye ce texte il ya quelques
instants et goûter c'est une décision de
la justice donc la justice fait son
enquête elle fait son travail et elle
mais monsieur benalla en garde à vue
bien avant je n'ai aucun commentaire à
faire que parce que s'ils commentaires
non pas sur la garde à vue mais sur le
fait que patrick strzoda a parlé devant
la commission denquête de falsification
faite par alexandre benalla pour obtenir
un passeport de service en est bien sûr
cette question là je peux vous répondre
puisque il s'agit de notre commission
denquête et c'est un fait qui est
maintenant avérée en tout cas les
déclarations de monsieur strzoda et très
affirmative hier montre qu il y a eu de
très grands dysfonctionnements et hier
nous en avons découvert de nouveaux nous
allons de contradictions en
contradictions de découverte en
découverte
et c'est vrai que il avait quatre
passeports plus le sien je suppose mais
c'est un collectionneur de passeport je
rappelle qu'il y a un passeport
diplomatique qui lui a été délivré le
jour même ou le lendemain où il n'avait
plus aucune fonction
et oui en matière d'organisation des
voyages les 24 mai après avoir justement
et bien et le ministère lui a délivré ce
qui est tout à fait étrange manque total
de coordination et alors ensuite il en a
fait part je crois au service du
protocole qui n'a pas réagi de les
services du protocole de l'elysée
d'autre part eu pour ce qui est du
passeport de service le de l'un des deux
passeports de service il en avait un
autre avant eh bien il est avéré
maintenant puisque monsieur strzoda l'a
déclaré sous serment qu'il a on va
entendre monsieur bénard on va
l'entendre qu'il aurait qu il a fait un
papier au nom du chef de cabinet le chef
de thema bien longtemps au courant
voilà pour un set de jonquière soeur
après la mise la garde à vue d'alexandre
reynal a confirmé par le parquet de
paris avant de se quitter on retourne
dans l'hémicycle où nous attend et
alexandre poussard puisque lé sénateur
s'empara du sujet du breakbeat cet après
midi oui les initiateurs vont débattre
du bric site pendant à peu près une
heure et demie et puis après ils vont
examiner un projet de loi commun dans sa
version avec la version de l'assemblée
nationale un projet de loi qui autorise
le gouvernement à prendre des
ordonnances en urgence pour réagir aux
briques cité notamment réagir à un break
site sans accord à ce qu'on appelle un
odile pour répondre à des questions
concrètes notamment régler le sort des
britanniques qui vivent en france et qui
après le break site n'auront plus la
liberté de circulation des citoyens
ordinaires de l'union européenne et puis
ce sont aussi les conséquences
économiques du break site qui
préoccupent les sénateurs avec un
chiffre un exemple en cas de brick site
sans accord le port de dunkerque devra
réaliser près de 25 millions d'euros
d'investissements en équipements pour
pouvoir fluidifier son trafic et
s'adapter au retour des contrôles
douaniers donc dans leur état d'esprit
les sénateurs ne se font pas d'illusions
il est peu probable qu'il y ait un
accord de sortie sur le break site et la
france doit s'y préparer
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes à
vos précisions à la fin de cette édition
remercia bon de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez revoir à les temps forts de la
science sont notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très bonne suite des
programmes sur la chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]
des pans entiers du littoral
disparaissent chaque année sous l'effet
de l'érosion des habitations sont
menacées
quelle est l'ampleur du phénomène
comment y répondre
est il possible d'accompagner les
communes les propriétaires la
législation est elle suffisante pour
répondre à ces situations nouvelles
ce sera notre débat de la semaine dans
un monde en doc un monde en doc samedi à
21h sur public sénat
[Musique]
amendement débat vote en séance dans un
instant linhai c'était vous présente
bon allez on est donc à charlie d'eau
qui est en train de crever oui quand on
est en train de faire la dernière fois
dans mon bobine a aujourd'hui une
émission culte qui a fait scandale dès
son quatrième numéro droit de réponse
animé par michel polac les missions
qu'on va vous diffusez c'est celle de
janvier 92 la fin de charlie hebdo
premières manières catherine sinet et
jean françois kahn qui participait à
l'émission sont avec moi en coproduction
avec l'ina rembobine a présenté par
patrick cohen dimanche à 21h
[Musique]